selenium is a portable framework for
testing web applications jim from
gymshape coding teaches this selenium
course
he has created many popular courses both
on the free co-cam channel and his own
channel hi everyone and welcome to the
python selenium series where we will
learn how to create user interface
automation for websites so selenium is
widely used and it is very popular for a
great reason because it can help you to
create tests for your web applications
and it can also help you to create
online bots which is very nice so in
this series we are going to learn how to
use selenium from the basics and later
on we will learn how to create an online
bot that will report the cheapest deals
from a booking website and this series
is really going to include some great
episodes so be sure to hit the subscribe
button and as well as click the bell
notification so you will never miss an
episode from this entire series
so grab a cup of coffee and let's get
started great so before we really get
started we need to understand that there
are going to be some prerequisites so in
this series i'm going to assume that you
have python installed and as well as you
got an ide like pycharm that is
configured properly with python now you
can also use a random text editor like
sublime text but just make sure that it
is connected properly to your system
interpreter and if you don't have any of
those then you can visit my five hour
beginners course and catch up with the
installations all right so like a lot of
libraries in the python programming
language we need to somehow use the
library of selenium so that's why we
need to somehow install it on our
computer and we can do that with the pip
command now if you got python installed
then you should also have the package
manager installed together with it so
now i'm going to open our terminal here
and i'm going to say pip install
selenium like that now i'm doing this in
the system interpreter because i'm not
going to use virtual environments
throughout this series so that's why i
could allow myself to do that from the
terminal okay so if you see no errors
then it means that everything is great
and we can go back to pycharm and
basically import this library and see
how we can use it all right so here i'm
going to import from selenium
import web driver so i'm importing
something very specifically inside this
selenium library and there's a great
reason for doing that now when it comes
to performing user interface automation
in web browsers then we need to somehow
open up that web browser so that's why
we need to import a dedicated library
that is going to automate us the action
of opening up a web browser now when we
talk about performing automations on a
web browser we need to understand that
for each web browser out there there is
going to be a version that is going to
be dedicated for performing those
automated tasks so for example if we
want to perform those automation tasks
on chrome browser then we need to
instantiate the chrome driver class to
perform those automated actions in it so
that's why we need to import that
library alright so now that we have
imported this then we have to
instantiate the library that is going to
be responsible to pop up the chrome
browser to us so that's why i'm going to
go down and i'm going to say for example
driver is equal to
[Music]
chrome
webdriver.com
that and as you can see here there's
actually more options rather than chrome
so if i delete that and i press on
control space then you can see that we
also got firefox and i believe that
there is edge as expected so as you can
see you can perform those automated
actions in different browsers but
actually throughout this series i'm
going to use chrome browser so that's
why i will say chrome and will
instantiate the class like that now we
could go ahead and try to execute this
but we will receive some arrows and the
arrows are going to talk about something
that is called chrome driver that does
not exist on my computer and as well as
it is not in the pad so let's break down
this error into two important steps that
we need to do so first of them we need
to download the chrome driver and
actually chrome driver is a separated
executable file that selenium webdriver
uses to perform those automated actions
in a chrome browser so that means that
we need to download this
chromedriver.exe
file to our computer so that's why i'm
going to bring here this website and i
will put the link of that in the
description for sure and as you can see
here is the page that we can download
the chrome driver and if we scroll down
then you can see that there are a lot of
versions of chrome driver that you can
download now you might ask yourself how
i'm going to decide which version should
be installed on my computer well this
depends on what chrome browser version
you have right now installed on your
computer so if you use the chrome
browser by default like me then what we
can do is basically go to a separated
tab and we can write here chrome column
two for slashes and then say version and
right after that we will see an output
like the following and as you can see
from here here is the google chrome
version that i use and as you can see we
have the major version as 89 so for
yourself it could be 90 91 92 or even 84
but you need to make sure that this
major version is going to be matched to
the version that you are going to
download from the chrome driver page so
in my case i'm going to go back now to
that page and i'm going to search up for
a version that is starting with 89 and
that's why i'm going to click here and
right after that i'm going to search for
the specific archive that i need and for
sure it is going to be windows because
that is the operating system of my
machine and i'm going to click here and
it should start downloading and right
after we have this downloaded then we
need to extract it because it is
actually a zip archive alright so as you
probably know in windows by default the
download files are going to be
downloaded in the downloads library and
you want to move this to a location that
you want to have your chrome driver so
for myself it is going to be under the c
drive and inside the folder that i named
selenium drivers as you can see in the
left side of my screen so i'm going to
cut this from here and move this to the
folder that i'd like to have it so i'm
going to do that and right after that
let's go ahead and work with this folder
now so as you can see the location of
that would be c selenium drivers like
that and you can again put it in
whatever location you like to and right
after that i'm going to extract the
files in here and as soon as i have done
this then you can see that we got the
executable file
located in this directory so it is a
great start to solving our problems that
we have when we try to execute this
python file perfect so back to python
now if we will try to execute this file
again then we will end up with the same
error and this is because we did not
perform the second step that i talked
about when we saw this error and we need
to now put the location of our chrome
driver in an environment variable that
is called path now the path environment
variable is going to be responsible for
the files that your system should look
up for when you want to execute them
immediately from the terminal so that's
why it should be inside the path
environment variable now we could have
done this in the system level but that
is actually a not great idea if one day
would like to perform this selenium
project on another server so that's why
configuring this environment variable in
the code level and not in the system
level is considered as a best practice
so that's why i'm going to say up top
here something like import os and i'm
going to now put one more value to the
already existing path environment
variable so i'm going to say os dot n
veron like that and then i'm going to
look up for the key of path and make
sure that you should do it all in
capitalize like i did and now we'd like
to use plus equals because we are adding
a path value to already existing path we
could have multiple values for this
environment variable and right here we
want to specify the location of our
chrome driver so i can start typing here
c colon and forward slash so i'm
pointing to the c drive of my computer
and i'm going to say here selenium
drivers like that because this is the
folder name where i have the chrome
driver all right so right after we have
done this then we should add here the r
letter before the double quotes and this
is actually a convention for a prefix
that is going to mark it as a row string
and it is going to be helpful when you
specify paths to different locations so
now if we were to try to execute this
program then we should see now the
chrome popped up and that is exactly
what is happening so it means that now
we are ready to work and start trying to
perform some automations on a random
website all right so now that we
understood how to set up a selenium
environment let's try to perform some
automation on a random website now in
this episode specifically i will start
by a testing selenium website which will
allow us to basically take basic actions
to get started with it so i'm going to
use this selenium easy.com website and
i'm going to go to this url in here
which i will put the link of that in the
description and i'm going to try to
click on that start download performing
it with the selenium only and right
after we click on that then we should
somehow identify that the progress has
been completed so actually those kind of
actions are good candidates for actions
that you want to perform with selenium
without really being involved in
clicking manually on those buttons so
let's go ahead and get started so first
of first we should understand how we are
going to identify the element that we
want to click on and in order to do
something like that we can go to the
element that we want and we can click on
inspect like the following now actually
when it comes to pages then each page is
going to have its unique html
architecture and each html element is
going to be described by its type and as
well as with some additional attributes
so let's see what i said in action so
i'm going to say inspect and as you can
see we have this line in blue background
and as i said the kind of this element
is button because we see that it is
right after the tags so that's why it is
called a button html element and as you
can see it has different attributes like
class id like that so what we can do
from here is to try to identify the
element that has the id of download
button like it says in here so let's try
to do and see how we can identify this
specific element and try to click on
that all right so let's go back to
pycharm now before i do that let me copy
the link of the website because we are
going to use it just in a minute all
right so now if i open pycharm and go
down and here we are ready to write some
additional code now before everything we
need to specify selenium what is the
website that we are going to use in our
automation so it should be done with the
get method that the driver is going to
have so i will say driver dot get and as
you can see it expects for a url so i
can straightforward put the link of the
url that we actually look to perform
some automatic actions so as you can see
this is the way that the driver dot get
should be executed all right so now that
we have done this then we should somehow
tell the selenium that we like to click
on an element that it's id is download
button so i'm going to say here driver
dot find underscore element
underscore by id and as you can see we
have multiple methods of find element by
so we have class name css selector and
even more like name and those are
methods that we are going to see in the
future throughout this series but let's
start with the id and i'm going to say
here download button
like the following now since this entire
statement is going to return us an
object that we can actually do some
additional actions with it then i should
assign this to a variable so i can say
my element something like that and then
down below i can say my element
dot click like that and we should see
selenium driver trying to click on that
element so let's test this out so i'm
going to execute that right now and i'm
not going to touch anything so let's see
that in action all right so it takes us
to here and as you can see it
immediately just click on that element
because we see that progress box that
saves us now that the download has been
completed but there's actually a bit
problem with doing this approach because
sometimes in most of the cases loading
an entire website could take some time
so that's why we can go between those
two lines and actually try to wait
before we try to perform an action on an
element so that's why going between
those lines and saying something like
driver that implicitly wait and here we
should specify the amount of seconds
that we'd like to wait to this website
to being loaded successfully so we can
say that we'd like to wait for example
three seconds so it's considered as a
better thing to do because now we are
totally safe from our browser being a
little bit slow sometimes or maybe we
can have some cases that our server
could be very slow so that's why waiting
a little bit here and there could be a
better idea so now if we run our program
one more time then let's see the results
so at first again the page is being
loaded and as you can see it immediately
tried to download this file now again
this is just a simulation this really
doesn't download anything to your
computer okay so let's identify what
happened in here so first of first we
can understand that it really did not
wait three seconds so what that means it
means that the implicitly weight does
something special to our driver object
because we did not really wait three
seconds right so let's try to test this
with 30 seconds now so i'm going to
execute this one more time and as you
can see just in a second it started to
download it once again so this really
does not wait in the amount of time that
is specified in this line so what is
going on here and why we saw the actions
being taken immediately well we could
have used here something like time dot
sleep and specify the amount of seconds
to wait but this is something that we
don't like to do here because sometimes
we don't like to wait for the complete
duration of time in case the element is
going to be found before the duration
specified it needs to move on to the
next line of code execution and so using
here the implicitly weight is actually
very very useful because again we don't
really need to wait 30 seconds if the
element is already there in that webpage
now to be fair there are more things
that i'd like to talk about this
implicitly wait because it has some more
functionalities that i will talk in the
future and if you have any questions
about the behavior of this tricky method
then let me know this in the comment
section down below alright so before we
go ahead and compare those kind of
weights then let's clear some important
points about the implicitly weight now
till that point we know that this is
much more efficient rather than typing
in time dot sleep because not always
we'd like to wait 30 seconds before we
find an element by id for example but
there is one piece of information that
we should know about the implicitly wait
it is going to be set up as a timeout
across all your selenium project so what
that means it means that you only need
to call this implicitly wait method one
time and then it will go ahead and set
an implicit weight amount for all the
elements that you are going to try to
find it in the future so for example i
might go down here and say something
like my second
element and i can make that to be equal
to driver dot find
element by id and i'm going to put here
some element that is not even existing
in the page in the left side so i can
say something like let's just write
something randomly and then i can
basically try to execute our program and
just for testing reasons let me decrease
this to eight seconds so we won't really
wait 30 seconds before we see this
program being crashed okay so if we run
this one more time then let's see the
results so as you can see we have no
problem with the first element but in
about a second or two we should receive
an error that the selenium was not able
to identify an element with this id in
here so that's actually an important
point to remember because once we set
the implicitly weight it is going to be
basically applied across all the
elements that we are going to try to
find them somehow in the future all
right so now that we completely
understood the behavior of implicitly
weight let's go forward with our
automation so now as a next step it
would have been nice to identify if the
download has been completed successfully
and we understood that to indicate
something like this we need to
understand when this text in here is
going to be exactly equal to complete
with an explanation mark so let's try to
write an automation like that so i'm
going to select everything in here and
try to click on inspect and let me do
this one more time because it did not
really point to it okay so we can see
that this complete with an explanation
mark is coming from this html element
which says us that its type is div and
it has the class of progress label now
till this point we did not really
identify a specific html element by its
class name and there's actually a great
way that we can do that by again using a
method with the prefix of find element
so let's see how we can do that so let
me delete this line actually and i will
stick with that one so i can say
something like progress
element is equal to driver dot find
element and then i can select a method
that is called by class name so we can
identify an element by its class name so
it is a great idea to select that and i
only need to now pass in the class value
so it will be
progress dash label as we saw earlier
now for those that are confusing what
are classes in the web world it is
basically a reference to a styling
method unlike with python which is
referring to classes where we use it for
object-oriented programming so i just
wanted to make sure that we don't
confuse between the meanings of class in
the web and now that i have this then i
can go to a new line and i can say here
something like print and i can use the
formatted string and i can try to
basically print the text of this element
so it will be by dot text and it should
display us the text in here so if we do
that and run this one more time let's
test the results of that okay so we have
a new page being appeared and as you can
see it immediately showed the text of
this element which was starting download
now showing up the text immediately is
actually not a great idea because we
probably like to wait some time until we
see the complete but there is actually
not a nice way to do this with the
approaches that we have learned till
this point so we need to use another
utility and for that there is something
that exists in selenium which is called
explicit weight now with this we can
actually allow our program to wait for
an expected condition and then we can
basically wait until this condition
returns true so what that means it means
that we look to this true expression in
here so i can say here completed
with the explanation mark and in our
case if we don't wait in a smart way
then we will always receive false with
that so we need to figure out how we can
wait till this condition is true and
let's go ahead and see how we can do
that all right so in order to use the
explicit weight we need to import some
several secondary libraries that is
inside the selenium so we are going to
say up top here something like from
selenium dot webdriver
dot common dot buy
import buy like that and we are also
going to import two more things in here
so it will be from selenium
dot web driver
dot support
dot ui like that we need to import the
built-in class inside this selenium that
is called web driver weight and we'd
also like to import one final thing
which is going to be selenium
dot webdriver dot support
import
expected
conditions
as ec both capitalized like that now i
know that it was a lot of info that we
have used as import but there's actually
a great reason for that and we will see
why just in a minute so now i will go
down here and i will start writing the
condition that we'd like to wait for now
in order to start with that then first i
will instantiate the web driver weight
class so i will say web driver weight
and i will instantiate that without
assigning it to a variable and at first
we need to pass in the driver object so
we will just say here driver and now we
like to specify the amount of seconds
that we should wait until the expected
condition is true or not so i'm going to
say here something like 30 seconds again
and that should be enough and then i'm
going to automatically launch the method
of until in here now by convention the
info that is written inside this until
method is usually in a separated line so
i'm going to press enter in here and
then we need to write the condition that
we want it to be true at some time and
in our case it is after 30 seconds
approximately so we can say here e c
which stands for expected condition that
we have used as import in here and we
can now use a method that says text
to
be
present
in
element so as we can understand this
method is designed basically to wait
until the text has the expected text and
i'm going to launch up this method in
here and again press enter so again i'm
just writing the arguments just in a
separate line now this method expects
for two important arguments as the first
one being the element that we'd like to
check the condition on and the second
one being the text that we expect to
have after 30 seconds so i will just
comment here those down so i will say
here element
filtration and as the second one we will
say the expected
text
like that all right so the way that we
are going to identify the element that
we'd like to check is by using the by
class now this is just another approach
finding elements in a web page so it is
not going to look complex so it is as
easy as saying here something like so i
will just create a tuple in here and
then i will start my filtration so we'd
like to find this again
by class name and as you can see we have
auto completion for that so i can just
use
class name like that and the second
piece of information right near of it
should be the class name value so it
will be progress dash label exactly like
before so this entire expression is just
another way to find an element in a web
page unlike using the find element by
class name method and i just realized
that i did not delete those two lines
that we don't need so let's go ahead and
do that and then in the second line
right after we say comma
we are going to write the expected text
so it is going to be complete with an
explanation mark so now if we run our
program then we should not receive any
errors because this condition is
probably going to return us through in
less than 30 seconds so if we run our
automation now and wait for the results
so again we click on this download
button and let's see just in a second
what will happen
all right so we got the text of complete
and if we go back to our program then
you can see that the program finished
successfully so what that means it means
that we were able to write a nice
automation until we have waited that
really verifies that the download of
some file has been completed
successfully so it is very nice to play
around between those weight methods we
can use implicitly weight to find
elements in our entire page and we can
also use the explicit weight which is
the more custom waiting so it means that
we need to use it if we want the
execution to wait for some time until
some condition is achieved now for
everyone that are interested to know
what are the expected conditions that
you can use you can do that by basically
seeing all the options in here so if we
delete everything from here and use dot
again and you can see that we have a lot
of options that we can use expected
condition for so you can see that we
have element to be clickable element to
be selected and basically wait for new
window is opened so as you can see there
are tons of options that you can use if
you would like to wait until some
expected condition is achieved so it is
very nice feature by selenium that we
can always use to write more dynamic
bots and as well as writing more
efficient test cases all right so the
reason you want to learn about sending
keys or clicking on different buttons
right after it is for performing actions
like login and registering accounts and
this is something very useful when you
want to overcome authorization in some
websites to basically performing some ui
testing or creating a bot for whatever
reason so to practice this i'm going to
pull up this website again from
seleniumez.com so that's actually the
page that we are going to try to send
keys to so as you can see in here we
have some html forms and actually when
we want to send the keys usually we'd
like to do it in html forms where we
actually need to write in some data and
then we need to click on some button to
submit our data so as you can see here
we have some form in here which asks for
two values and then if we were to click
on get total then you can see that it
shows us 30 and if i change this to
actually some other number then you can
see that it is being updated so that is
what we are going to try to automate now
with selenium so first let me grab the
website of this section in here and go
back to pycharm and actually say here
driver dot get and the link will be
available in the description for sure so
you can directly copy and paste from
there all right so now i will paste this
in and right after we have done this
then we should somehow again try to
identify the element in some method by
id class name or whatever method it will
be so i will go back to our website in
here and as usual i will say inspect and
you can see that we have here something
that is called class which we can again
find the element by its class and as
well as id now i always like to filter
by id because i think that this is the
strongest field that is always unique so
i'm going to use this id sum1 and i
believe that the second
box in here should be sum2 so if i check
that
with inspect then you can see that it is
just as expected so we need to pull
those elements and basically try to send
some keys to it so i'm going to go back
to pycharm and i will say here
sum one is equal to driver dot find
element by id and i can use someone in
here and i can do the exact same thing
by basically copying this in here and
paste this in and change the values to
number two like that and then i can try
to send some keys so it will be just as
easy as pulling the element because now
we have full access to it and basically
launch the method of send keys like that
now you can put here whatever you would
like to as you can see it expects for a
value so this could be any value that
you would like to pass in here it could
be a string or it could be directly a
number like that so let's go with
numbers and say 15 like we have done
manually and i will do the same thing
with sum tool so i will send 15 as well
and now we can actually test this out
and see if it works but not before we go
ahead and say here something like driver
dot implicitly wait and it is enough to
wait five seconds in here for each
element and now we can test this out so
if i run our program then let's see the
results
okay so the page has been loaded and you
can see that we received this message
and we will handle it in a minute but
you can see in the background that we
got the values so i know that it is a
bit transparent in here but you can
actually see this in the background okay
so i think we got a new challenge in
here as we see this output and we need
to somehow perform an automation to
click on no thanks to continue our
automation so this is actually a good
candidate to handle things along the way
so now i can go to inspect in here and
see what needs to be done to basically
identify this button in here and click
on that before we go ahead with our
automation okay so you can see that we
got this element with multiple classes
and if i take a look in here then you
can see that we have some classes in
here that are separated by spaces now if
you see classes separated by white space
as i said then it means that it is
referring to a different class so i can
actually try to filter this element by
class name
a t dash c m
no dash button as it will probably the
most unique class name that i can try to
filter this element by so i can go
here and actually use
let me copy this down and manipulate
this in pycharm so before we go with
everything in here let me please go down
here and paste this text in here and as
you can see this is the class name that
we'd like to filter by so i will delete
everything and i will cut this string
from here and i will say
no
button is equal to driver dot find
element by class name and i will paste
back the class name that we'd like to
filter by and now that i have done this
then i can basically apply the click
method so it will be
no button dot click like that now one
final thing that it is a great idea to
do here is to wrap this with try accept
block because not always we are going to
find an element by this class name
because maybe in the next time this
pop-up won't appear so it is a great
idea to use here try and basically
locate those two lines under a try block
and then if the selenium is not going to
find any element with that class name
then it will not crash our program
because in the accept block we can only
say something like print
no element with this class name so i can
say just skipping
like that all right and down below i can
continue with our automation exactly
like that okay so if we run our program
here then let's see what will happen
this time so the page has been opened
and as you can see now we don't see the
pop-up and we don't see any message from
the accept block so what that means it
means that the selenium identified the
element with this class name and it
immediately clicked on that button that
we wanted to click on from the first
stage and then it went ahead and
basically executed the rest of the lines
of code and you can see that the values
are right there so we are pretty close
to complete the automation that we
wanted to complete now there is one
final thing that i'd like to show you
before we go ahead with the get total
element and i'm talking about the fact
that we can send keys directly not only
specifying the text that we'd like to
send so what that means it means that we
can send the keys like shift alt enter
control and stuff like that and the way
that it is going to work is by importing
the
keys class from the selenium and that is
something useful here and there that you
want to basically automate some actions
that are required to maybe copy some
text so you need to automate control c
and again that's useful because
sometimes you want to automate pressing
on some key directly rather than sending
some random text so
i'm going to import here from
selenium.webdriver.common
dot keys import
keys like that and inside this class you
have all the options that are basically
the keyboard keys that are existing in
each keyboard so to show you that then
i'm going to now change this to
something like keys
dot and as you can see in the drop down
we have all the options so we even have
f1234 and we even have the nums that are
existing in the right side of our
keyboard which is in numpad so if we
want we can send the keys from the
numpad i know that it is not quite
useful for that case but again sending
keys directly could be very very useful
in some cases when you need them so as
you can see you have all the options in
here and if one day you want to take a
look to all the options then you can
always go here and basically use ctrl b
in pycharm or f12 in visual code and you
can inspect to that class and you can
see that all the options are here
available and this is very very useful
now to prove you that it will work then
let me try this with the numpad so in
the sum 1 i will send numpad
1 and i will also send pay attention
that i can separate the values by comma
and i can say here keys dot numpad
5 and then it will basically send 15 so
it is going to be quite equivalent to
what we have done and to show you that
it works then i can basically launch our
program again and you can see down below
that the results are quite the same so
that is just another approach of sending
keys and the beauty behind of it it is
the fact that you can send all the
keyboard keys that exist out there
alright so now we only have the get
total button to filter now not always
we'd like to filter the html elements by
their id or class name we might have
some more attribute key value pairs that
we can try to filter the elements by so
now i'm going to go to inspect in here
and
let me do this again and as you can see
we have here an attribute that we did
not see before which is on click now say
that i'd like to filter this element by
on click equals to that value in here
and this is something that we did not
learn how to do till that point and this
is possible with something that is
called css selector and css selector is
a pattern to filter an element by its
styling now unlike with the methods of
find element by id or class name with
css selectors we don't always need to
filter an element that matches an exact
string so for example with css selectors
it is an option to identify an element
by only searching a substring that it
contains now that is extremely useful
because not always we'd like to filter
element by exact key value match because
we could want to perform something with
elements that are having the same prefix
or suffix so let's see how css selectors
works in action all right so we are back
at pycharm and let's go down and see how
we can use the css selector so i'm going
to say here button is equal to driver
dot find
element by
css selector like that and in here we
need to pass our css selector expression
and the way that we are going to do that
is by using some
special pattern that exists out there
now to select an element by css selector
you have multiple options but we are
going to use the pattern of html element
type followed by a matching key value
now as an example we can actually go
back to our button and see how we are
going to filter that and you can see
that it's a type of button and we can
see that from here and it has the key
value of on click return total so that
means that we can try to filter all the
buttons out there that are having the
attribute of on click with the value of
return total like that so to
achieve this we will go back here and we
will say button and then we will need to
open a square brackets and we will need
to say here something like on
click
equals and then we will use
double quotes in here now the reason i
use double quotes it is because i used
single quotes here from the beginning
and we do not want to mismatch those and
now in here i can say return
total like that and as you can see this
is the one way that a css selector could
work you can basically specify the html
element followed by the key value match
and make sure that it is inside the
square brackets right after it now i'm
going to show later on all the css
selector options because there are tons
of options that you can filter an
element by css selector okay so i expect
this button to basically have the html
element of this button and then i can
basically use button dot click as
expected so now we can test if this
works so if we
run our automation once again let's see
what will happen all right so down below
you can see that we received the text of
total a plus b is 30 and that is exactly
the result that we expected for so what
that means it means that we were able to
select an element by css selector
successfully and that is perfect all
right so i said earlier that i will show
you the page where i took this css
selector expression pattern and you can
see that now i'm in a page that has
multiple examples of how you can filter
elements by using css selector so you
can see that we have a table with all
the selector options and as well as some
additional examples for all the patterns
so you can see that if we scroll down
then i actually used those patterns so
this is a pattern that is containing the
element type and in this example the
type is a and that stands for anchor and
you can see that within the square
brackets in here it looks for a matching
key value but in that case as i said
earlier you can not only search for an
element that includes an exact string
you can also search for an element that
contains some string so you can see that
in the description it says
selects every a tag
elements whose href attribute value
begins with https
and same goes when you want to select
some elements that ends with some text
so you can see that we have a lot of
options in here and that is very useful
and i can totally confirm that the css
selector is the method that i use the
most because it gives you much much
control rather than the other elements
so it helps you really to find the
elements that you look up for when you
want to perform some automation on them
all right so the first thing that we
want to do is to dedicate a file for the
project now before i started recording
this then i already have created this
bot folder so this is going to include
the code for our project and you can go
ahead and create the folder wherever you
want just make sure that you connect
this to python so i will click ok and we
will start from here now you can pay
attention that by default pycharm
created for us the main dot py file so
we can just basically delete everything
from here and continue working so if the
auto generated file is not happened to
you then just go ahead and create a new
file by yourself and name it main like
that okay so now i'm going to basically
start designing the structure of the
project and the way that i'm going to
structure this project is going to be as
i described in my project structure
video on my channel now if you don't
know what i mean then i have a video
that describes how a python project
should be structured whether it's a
beginner project or an advanced project
so if you want to take a look then you
can click in the suggested link so now
i'm going to go ahead and create a
subdirectory that is named booking like
that and i'm doing this because i want
to include all the relevant code to the
booking bot inside this directory and
then this main dot py file is going to
go ahead and basically call the
necessary python files from this
directory and let me go ahead and change
this to run actually it is just more
comfortable to me so i will go ahead and
do that all right so inside this booking
directory we will start by creating
three files so let's go ahead and create
the first of them so the first one is
going to be named booking like that and
here i'm going to have a class that is
going to have some instance methods that
we're going to call them in order to
make our bot to perform some actions and
the second one is going to be constants
so we are going to have a lot of values
that we really want to change throughout
the execution of our project so that's
why separating those variables in
another file that we can name it
constant is a great idea so i'm going to
go ahead and do that and the other file
that i'm going to create for now is
going to be called by the following way
so it will be underscore twice in it
underscore twice once again and there's
actually a great reason that i'm naming
this file the way it is it is because
this is a convention when you want to
create a python package now the reason
you want to create a python package it
is because we want to call the package
from this run.py file now notice how the
run.py file is outside of the booking
directory and that is one more reason
that i have created this double
underscore init double underscore file
it is just a convention to mark this
directory as a python package now i will
use a few more seconds to explain
something very special about the double
underscore unity file as well so say
that we go to run.py file and we look to
import something from the constants file
in order to execute something
successfully so we could say something
like from booking dot constants import a
for example now i know that this
variable doesn't really exist so we can
create it like that and notice that now
i'm inside the constants and if i go
back to run then we are totally fine now
before i do this let me go to the double
underscore init file and say
i will print first now what i am meaning
in here it is the fact that no matter
which sub module you are importing from
the
booking directory at first the double
underscore init file is always going to
be executed so to prove you that then
i'm going to
execute the run dot py file which
basically imports just a variable from
the constants file so if i go ahead and
run it then you can see that we receive
this message so that is one more
important behavior that we should be
aware of when it comes to python
packages and we are going to use this
advantage in our project as well but i
just want to make sure that you
understand the behavior of python
packages and now we are totally ready to
go ahead and start building our bot now
kind of a disclaimer alert before we
start i will not recommend running this
bot around while through or running it
every few seconds because it might lead
the server side to automatically disable
your public ip address and it is always
not nice because then you have to
contact to that website and explain that
you did not mean to do any harm so
that's why be sure to give enough room
when you test your bot on those large of
websites like the one that we are going
to use which is booking.com all right so
i have deleted everything that i have
shown you previously as example now we
are ready to go and write our class now
i said that we are going to make this
project object oriented so this file
that i named booking.py file is going to
be responsible to describe the methods
that later on we are going to call them
and those methods are going to take the
actions that we want our bot to take so
let's get started now first we want to
import the web driver from the selenium
library so we can create a class that
will inherit from some utilities inside
this selenium library so we will start
by saying from selenium import web
driver and then we will go down two
lines and we will say class booking so
this is actually a good name for our
class and now this class is going to
inherit from
webdriver.chrome and the reason we want
to do this it is because i want the self
object to have the option of both using
the
methods and also the methods that i will
design for the class booking itself so
now i can go inside our class and excuse
me for this backslash and design the
double underscore init method now this
is the constructor of our class so this
method is going to be called immediately
once we instantiate an instance of this
class so we will say def double
underscore init like that and we will
receive one parameter that i can name
that driver pat like that and if you
remember this is going to store
information about the location of our
drivers now just to save us a little bit
of time then i'm going to receive a
default value for this parameter which
is going to be exactly the value that i
have used throughout the first three
episodes of this selenium series so it
will be r for row string and i will open
here double quotes and i will say c
column backslash selenium
drivers like that because this is the
location that i have the chrome driver
okay so now i can go down and say self
dot driver pad is equal to driver path
and further than that i will say super
and the reason i use the super in here
it is because i want to instantiate the
webdriver.chrome
class along the way and the reason i
want to do this it is because the
constructor is going to complain about
how the inherited class is not
instantiated yet so this is why i can
allow myself to use the super method to
do so now if you never saw me using the
super method then i actually have a
video from a series that i have created
a year ago that you can watch a video
that is dedicated for class inheritance
so i will put the link in the suggested
video up top alright so this super is
going to receive the name of the current
class as an argument and as well as the
self object and now i'm going to call
the double underscore init method of the
webdriver.com class as well so this line
is going to be successfully instantiate
an instance of the webdriver.com class
as well and to prove you that let's go
down and design a random method so let's
say here something like def
lend
first page
and receive self as a parameter for sure
because this is an instance method and
now if i was to say self
dot get then you can see that i have
full access to the methods of the
webdriver.com class and you can see that
i can also make use of find element by
something and as well as using the get
method so those methods are familiar to
us because we saw them in the beginning
of this series so this is perfect now i
have a class that i can use the selenium
methods to play around with the action
that we want to take with our online bot
all right so i'm actually going to make
use of this method and i'm going to
point our bot to the first location that
we want to do so and i'm going to use
here the get method and as the url i'm
going to pass in the url of the website
that we are trying to make an online bot
on so it will be
https www.booking.com
now actually here is the exact reason
that i have created the constants.py
what we can do in that case this value
in here is probably a value that is not
going to change so commonly because this
is the website that we are going to
always use so that's why moving this
value to a file that i already created
like constants dot py is a perfect idea
so we can make use of this file by
storing some constants and by convention
in programming when we have constants
then we should use all uppercase so i'm
going to say base underscore
url is equal to the exact url in here
and now i can go back to our booking.py
and i can use
importbooking.constance
like that as const just to make it
shorter and easier to read and i can go
now and say const dot base url and now
we are ready to continue from here now
actually before we test this out if you
remember before we instantiated the
webdriver.chrome class in the first
three episodes then we had to do
something that is quite mandatory
because otherwise the selenium is going
to complain that it does not have the
driver path in the system level path
variable so that's why we used something
that was looking like
always.nbron if you remember so let's do
this before we use this super method
because again otherwise the selenium is
going to complain for that error so i'm
going to go up top here and i'm going to
say import os and i'm going to
go down and i'm going to use here os dot
environ and i'm going to access to the
path variable and i'm going to use plus
equals
and then i will add the self.driver
pad like that now if you don't remember
what this does definitely consider
watching the first episode maybe for a
minute or two but let me bring the code
from the first episode so i'm inside my
repository on github that i have
published recently when i launched this
series and if we take a look then you'll
see that i used in the very beginning
this line that adds this
pad to the path variable so that's why i
have basically used the same expression
pretty much inside our class all right
so let's go back to pycharm and continue
and now what we can basically do is go
to our run.py file and import this class
and create an instance of it so we can
really use its methods like land first
page so if we go to run.py file and zoom
in a bit and say from booking
actually it should be from
booking.booking because we want to refer
to the file name as well we only want to
import the booking class which i named
like that and now i can say inst is
equal to a booking instance and i'm not
going to pass anything because i want to
make use of the default value of this
driver pad and now i can really try to
use the first method that we have
launched so it will be inst dot
land first page so this line is going to
be responsible to take our bot to the
booking.com homepage so now i can
execute the run.py file and test if
everything works so if i run that then
let's see what will happen okay so you
can see that we are inside the page that
we were interested to be at from the
very beginning and now we can continue
on basically designing our bot from here
now there are going to be tons of
actions that we want to take to
basically fill in the form of where we
are going or the dates that we'd like to
check in plus check out and as well as
adding more people to our vacation so
the combination of all of those are
going to be divided into instance
methods and the fact that we do that is
going to make our code a lot more
readable and maintainable so that's why
using here object oriented is a perfect
idea because it gives you the option to
extend your application if you want to
do that later on all right so there's
going to be one more very interesting
thing that we want to design at this
stage now you could pay attention that
although we only wanted to launch the
index page then we still got the driver
instance being opened so what that means
it means that on our next testing the
chrome browser is still going to be
opened and this can lead us to have like
10 or even 20 browsers opened on our
computer now sometimes when we test
something then we immediately want to
force our browser being closed once the
bot has finished doing its job so that's
why sometimes we want to have control
whether if we like to quit the
application of chrome or leave it open
so this is a good candidate for why we'd
like to use context managers because
using context managers could give us a
lot more control when we want to start
something and when we want to tear down
things up so that's why i'm going to
make use of context managers throughout
this project so in order to implement
this then let me show you what needs to
be done in the class level and if you
did not hear about context managers yet
then i'm going to give here a short
explanation about it but basically if
you want to learn about it more deeply
then i have a video that is dedicated
for context managers in python so if you
want definitely consider taking a look
in the suggested link but let's go and
cover this up so i'm going to go to
booking.py file and i'm going to use two
more magic methods that will allow us to
basically make use of context managers
now the way that context managers are
being used on the instance level is by
instantiating an instance of a class
with the
with keyword and to simulate to that
then i'm going to split the panes now
horizontally i believe no we should do
this excuse me i'd like to do that
vertically all right so on the left pane
i'm going to have our booking.py file
and on the right pane i will have the
run.py file so on the right side i'm
going to now delete everything and i'm
going to say wait
booking
like that as
bought and then i will go here and i
will say bot dot land first page now the
beauty of using something like that it
is the fact that once python reaches the
line outside of the indentation then it
is going to execute some tear down
actions and the location that we'd like
to define those tear down actions are by
convention used under the magic method
that is called double underscore exit so
to implement that then i'm going to go
here and i'm going to say def
double underscore exit and i'm just
going to use the suggestion of pycharm
because by default it receives some more
parameters and i don't want to screw
things up so i'm going to just press
enter on the suggestion of python so
now i can say self
dot
quit so quit is going to be the method
that is going to be responsible to shut
down the chrome browser once we have
finished everything now to preview that
then i'm going to run this
and i'm going to say inside the
indentation exiting
like that and now let's try to run the
run.py file one more time and see what
will happen so i'm going to run that
and
once we received the page then you can
see that we have exiting and right after
it the chrome browser has shut down so
what that means it means that once
python gets out of the indentation of
weight expression then it executes
automatically the double underscore exit
method this is how context managers are
working and to have something like this
when we want to test multiple things
through how the development of this
project is perfect now to extend the
option of when we want to tear down or
when we don't want to tear down then we
can basically receive here one more
parameter so i'm now inside the booking
file then i can say teardown
is equal to false by default and i can
say under the exit method something like
if teardown so this basically refers
sorry this should be self.teardown
and we should go
here and say self.teardown
equals to teardown and then i can
basically use here an if statement and
say
self.teardown so if this is true then
run the self.exit but if this is false
then
just don't do anything and leave the
browser open and now when i want to
basically tear down then i can pass in
here teardown equals to true or i cannot
pass it and if i don't pass it then the
browser will remain open so again this
is a good way to have a control whether
if you want to close up your browser or
you want to leave it open because maybe
sometimes you want to test something
else rather than just testing the
selenium code now let me also remove the
exiting line now that we understood this
and i think that will be it about the
context manager so i hope that you
understood the concepts of how context
managers are working all right so at
that stage we have left the previous
tutorial and we understood in the
previous episode how we use this booking
class in order to have more control in
our webdriver.com class and we also
designed some methods that could be
helpful like the double underscore exit
so we could have the option of using
context managers when we instantiate an
instance of this booking class and we
also have designed this method in here
which is looking like land first page
and it basically lands the bot on this
const.baseurl
which is booking.com that is located in
the consons.py file okay so now before
we go ahead and understand what are the
next steps let me do two more actions
that are going to be quite useful for us
to have more control so the first one is
going to be to adding the implicitly
weight method and just a quick reminder
implicitly weight is the method that
will allow us to wait for some amount of
time until the element is ready on the
website so if we were to say self dot
implicitly wait and for example pass in
here 15 seconds then no matter which
method is going to be executed with the
prefix of find element then it is going
to wait approximately 15 seconds but it
could also proceed to the next find
element method by less time because not
always we'd like to wait 15 seconds and
this method is going to take
responsibility for that and the second
line of code that i'd like to add in
here is going to be self dot
maximize window and the reason i want to
do this it is because i just want to
have a cleaner look when i test the bot
so now let me go and
run our run.py file and now you can see
that the web browser has been opened in
maximize window so it is more nicer and
you can also see that we are inside
booking.com as expected all right so now
that we have done this then the next
step in here is probably going to
automate clicking on choose your
currency now you might have to think
that we should automatically automate
the where are you going and as well as
the check-in checkout dates and
selecting how many people we are but
actually at first it might be a great
idea to change the currency so we will
have like a more common look to all the
deals that are going to be resulted
after we search for them so now let's
basically understand what we need to
automate so we need to automate clicking
on that and right after it we need to
automate clicking on usd or euro or
whatever currency we look for now for
the purposes of this tutorial i'm going
to try to automate clicking on usd
because basically this is one of the
popular currencies out there so this is
what we should do we should basically
click on this one and right after that
we should somehow try to click on that
one and then you can see that right
after we have clicked on that then the
currency has been changed and then we
are ready to try to send some text in
where are you going text box so now
let's try to understand how we are going
to automate clicking on that so i'm
going to click right click and click on
inspect so we can understand which
element is responsible to display this
button
now i'm not sure why i have to do it
twice always but i really did not figure
this out yet but if this is happening to
you as well then maybe try to do it once
again and it will basically color the
element in the blue background as
expected so i will do that one more time
and you can see that this button is
actually what's responsible to display
this currency element so now when we try
to identify an element with selenium
then we should always try to be
small enough to identify this element in
the most unique expression as we can now
the attribute of id is actually the most
unique attribute that an html element
could have but not always we are going
to have id for html elements so that's
why we need to figure out other
approaches to find that element and in
our case maybe you could have thought to
find this element with the class is
equal to buy button but actually this
might not be the most smart way to do
that because there might be some other
buttons with that class as classes in
html are for styling elements so
multiple buttons could have the same
styling so that's why maybe filtering
this button with the data tooltip text
is equal to choose your currency is a
more unique expression that we can use
so
now i'm going to
copy this expression from here and i'm
going to basically identify it with css
selector method that we have learned in
the third episode so i'm going to go
back to pycharm and down below i'm going
to say def
change currency and i will also receive
currency as a parameter in here so that
maybe we could have the option to change
to different currency rather than united
states dollars so i'm going to say
currency and down below i'm going to say
self dot find element by css selector
and i will open up and close and i will
press enter because i don't want to make
the lines of code too much long so that
it is a great idea to separate them in
the following way and i'm going to now
open up a single quote and i'm going to
use button and
open and close square brackets now if
you remember this is how we use to work
with css selectors we first wrote the
type of html element and then inside we
wrote the expression that we should
filter this button by and this is going
to be data tooltip text is equal to
choose your currency and then it is a
great idea to assign this whole
expression to a variable so i'm going to
say
currency underscore element is equal to
that one and down below i can say
currency underscore element dot click so
it will automate clicking on that now
let me change this parameter to have a
default value so we will not really have
to pass the value all the time so now
i'm going to open up the run.py on the
right side so let me split that
vertically and let me open this in here
like that and then let me call this
button so it will be bought dot change
currency like that and then let me run
this run.py file and test the results so
as expected we are on the homepage and
you can see that we have automated
clicking on the change currency element
so that is nice that is a great first
step to achieve our goal now the next
thing that we look to automate is
probably to clicking on one of the
currencies and for the purposes of this
tutorial let me first show how we could
identify the usd now in the future we
have a parameter that receives the
currency type so maybe we could choose
from the rand.py a different currency
that we can automate to click on so let
me use
inspect again
so we could identify this element and
now if i click on this element to expand
its inner html elements then you can see
that in here we have this text and this
text as well but actually the whole
button is coming from this anchor tag
because if i take my mouse to here and i
hover it then you can see that we have a
green background surrounded our currency
so that's why maybe we should try to
find this a element and we should use
something that will help us to identify
this a tag now i have expanded the view
of the inspect in here so we can have a
cleaning look and you can see that we
have here some key value attributes
again now i can try to
find
data model header async url parent
something like that
that is containing the text that looks
like selected underscore currency is
equal to usd now i know that we did not
learn how to find elements that contains
some substrings but this is actually
very easy with the css selector method
as well so let's see in pycharm how we
can do that all right so down below i'm
going to use a new variable that we can
name it selected currency
element and that is going to
be self dot find element by css selector
and here we are going to write the
expression again so it will be single
quotes a and then we will use square
brackets and now we will use this long
expression that will help us to identify
this element so it will be data
dash
model dash
header
dash
async
dash again url dash param like that so i
know that this is a long expression but
this is actually a great approach to
identify this element and that is going
to include a substring so besides doing
equals to then we should use asterisk
equals now i know that again this is not
something that i have covered in the
first three episodes but now we know how
we can try to find an expression that
contains substring and it is as easy as
using the asterisk sign near the equal
sign and then i'm going to use here
double quotes and i'm going to say
selected
currency
is
equal to usd like that now if you
remember then this is actually the value
that this long key had in this element
that we looked to automate so now we
could say selected currency dot click
and this should be enough to basically
automate clicking on the usd currency
now you may think to yourself why did
you hard code this usd in here besides
you did not use the currency parameter
so that is a wonderful point and i'm
going to just change it now so i'm going
to add here a formatted string and i'm
going to refer to the value of the
currency like that and then what i'm
going to do now is going to run that py
by again splitting the panes
and working on run dot py and i'm going
to pass in currency is equal to usd
like the following and then this line
will be responsible to basically replace
this expression with the usd string and
this should be enough so let's test this
out so i'm going to run our program
all right so you can see that the
currency has been changed to usd now we
could also test this one more time by
trying to click on a totally different
currency so let's go with g b p all
right so let's try to do that so let's
open the pycharm again and besides
sending usd let's send g b
p
and run our program again and let's see
now what will happen
all right so again perfect so as you can
understand we have identified the
perfect key value expression to identify
the element for changing the currency
and from here we are ready to go forward
with the next steps that our bot should
do in order to search for the best deals
all right so now that we have completed
the changing currency method then let's
design the next method that we should do
now so if you remember we should now try
to identify an element for sending some
text to the search text form element so
if we
run our automation again just to have
the browser being opened in booking.com
and wait for this automation being
completed then now we should automate
sending some text to this area so i'm
going to inspect again and i'm going to
try to find the most smart expression as
i can to send text to this form field
now i said earlier in this tutorial that
if our elements are including the id
attribute then this is actually the
strongest attribute that the element
could have to basically identify its
uniqueness so that's why i'm going to
identify an element by the id with the
value of s twice so
now i can go and say in a new method in
pycharm something like death
select place
to go something like that and i can
basically
receive a parameter that will say place
to
go and now i can go down and say
search field
is equal to let me make the font bigger
so excuse me if you did not see the text
quite well so i'm going to say here self
dot find element
by id and i'm going to find this by s
twice like that and at first i'm going
to do something that we
really did not see before which is
looking like search field
dot clear so clear stands for cleaning
the existing text so if one day we'd
like to search something twice then
maybe we will have some leftovers so
that's why cleaning the entire text at
first place is a great idea before we
write some new fresh text so that's why
i launched the clear method and then i'm
going to use search field
dot send underscore keys and i'm going
to basically send place to go that is
arriving from this parameter and then
i'm going to go to run.py and i'm going
to say
bot dot select
place to go and let's
use here new york as the first place to
go and now let's see what will happen so
i'm going to
run our automation again
and test the results
now by the way we could comment out the
changing currency code just because we
don't want to probably execute it every
time we test a new area in our bot so
i'm going to do that just in a minute
all right so you can see that the minute
that i have wrote some text then we
received a drop down so what that means
it means that we need to go now and
identify the first result of our of our
drop down and we need to automate
clicking on that so
this is exactly what i'm going to do now
i'm going to click inspect
on the drop down
and
i'm going to do that one more time and
you can see that this is the value that
we should automate clicking on that so
this is actually an attribute with the
tag of li now li is actually standing
for a list html field that is basically
commonly used if we want to display a
list of elements so that's why we see
this tag with the name of li now we
should again try to find how we are
going to click on this li so this is
this element i believe yeah and then if
we expand this a little bit more then we
will have a cleaner look now
you can see
that inside each li we have an attribute
that says data dash i is equal to some
string now i know that it is hard to see
but if you will look in the bottom left
then you can see that once i point on
that element then the first result of
our drop down is being shown with
green background and if i was to move my
mouse to that element then you can see
that it now points to the second result
of the drop down so what that means it
means that the data i value is actually
like an index of all the results because
the first result is having the value of
zero and the second one is having the
value of one and the third result is
having the value of two and so on so
that's why we could identify an element
with the expression of data dash i is
equal to zero so i'm going to open our
pycharm and i'm going to say right under
select place to go something like
first result is equal to
self dot find element by css selector
and our expression is going to look like
l i and square brackets again and it
will be data
dash i
is equal to
zero like that and then right after we
have done this then we are going to say
first result dot click like that and
then i'm going to leave everything as it
is because those lines are going to be
responsible to basically click on the
first result and this is exactly what we
want to do so i'm going to run run.py
and test the results once again
and i forgot to uncomment this section
so excuse me for that and now you can
see that we got a perfect result we
automated clicking on the first result
of the drop down and hence we have done
that then booking.com automatically took
us to the check-in check-out
area so here's the exact place that we
can already try to automate selecting
check-in dates and as well as check-out
date so this is great and this means
that we have done a wonderful job
identifying how we could click on that
specific element all right so this was
the stage that we have left the previous
tutorial now as you remember when we
selected the location that we'd like to
go then booking.com by default popped up
the check in or check out date that the
user can select so it means that we can
automatically try to select the check in
date and as well as the check out date
now the time that i record this video
will be may 2021 so if for yourself you
are seeing a totally different result
then it probably means that you are
watching this in some another date so
the results are going to be different
for you but i'm going to write a method
that will be generic enough to support
any kind of date so let's go ahead and
get started so we need to somehow click
on two dates as the first one will
represent the check in and the second
one will represent check out so i will
just click on that right click and say
inspect we do that one more time and
then i will go to the inspect window and
let's see how we are going to automate
clicking on those buttons so you can see
that it is actually this one and it is a
child element of this td element now td
stands for table data and what that
probably means it means that this
element is part of a bigger html tag
that is called table which is designed
for creating html tables and this is
also how this page represents the
calendar as you can see the table in
here and when i hover my mouse you can
see that it totally gets colored with
blue background so now this means that
we need to somehow automate clicking on
this one and we can actually use css
selector again by
selecting an element with data date
equals to some date as you can see in
this case it is 2021
0 5 16. so i'm going to copy this
statement and i'm going to go back to
pycharm and let's try to automate that
so down here in booking.py
right where our booking class is i'm
going to type in one more method that we
can call it something like select
check
or we can just call it select date
something like that and then we will
receive two parameters like check in
date and as well as a check out date and
we can go down and we can say check in
element is equal to self dot find
element by css selector
and this is going to have as an argument
the following statement so i will open
single quotes and i will use td because
this is the element we look to automate
and then we will open up and close
square brackets and we will paste in the
statement that we'd like to identify the
element by so now you can see that this
state is hard coded in here and i'm just
going to use formatted string and
replace the value from being hard coded
to have the value of check in date which
we receive as parameter and then it
totally makes sense to go down and say
check in element
dot click and then we are going to do
this exactly same thing for the check
out date because this is how we are
going to select a range of date for
deciding the dates of our vacation
so i'm going to go down and i'm going to
say check out date
element excuse me and it should be equal
to self dot find element by cs selector
one more time and i'm just going to use
the same statement like we did with
check in and i'm going to replace the
check in date with check out date so
down below we can again use check out
element dot click and this should be
enough to basically decide the check-in
and check out dates and the only thing
that we have to do now is go back to our
run.py and execute this method by
passing in two arguments so it will be
bought dot
select dates and we are going to pass in
check-in date is equal to let's say
2021-05
for may and then day of the month will
be 16 and then we are going to do the
same for check out date and we will pass
in
2021 0 5 23 for example all right so
let's go ahead and test our program now
we understand that we don't have to
really test the change currency anymore
because this works so i can allow myself
to comment this just for now
alright so let's run this out
and see what happens
okay so this works very well and you can
see that we have the check in and check
out dates now let me tell something very
important in here actually let's say
that you would like to automate for
selecting dates that are two months or
three months from today so this is
something that i'm not going to show in
this tutorial but you have all the
utilities to basically achieve this by
yourself so say that you want to select
some date that is going to be four
months from today so this means that you
have to automate clicking on this next
button three times and then you will
have the option to select range of dates
that is four months from today which in
my case will be september 2021. so i
just wanted to mention that i know that
this program is not going to support
selecting vacations in dates like five
months or six months from today but
again you have all the tools that you
can try to automate this action by
yourself all right so the next thing
that i'm going to straightforward show
in here is how we can select the adults
to decide our vacation and to do that we
need to first simulate clicking on this
area and then we are basically looking
for automating clicking on this minus
sign or this plus sign to basically
decide the adults now again we will try
to write a method that will basically
receive a perimeter with adults count
something like that and then we will try
to simulate deciding the adults for our
vacation now i'm not going to show for
children or rooms because this is going
to be probably the same logic that we
need to repeat but again you have the
option to extend your bot in whatever
way you'd like to alright so now first
of first let's start identifying this
entire area in here so
inspect
and do that again all right so we look
for the element that will basically
color the entire area of this
selection button so i think this should
be this label with the id of
xp
guests toggle so i know that the font is
a little bit small in here but this is
basically what it says here it says to
us xp guess toggle so i'm going to just
copy this value and i'm going to
go to our bot and i'm going to go down
and write one more method that we can
again name it something like death
select
adults
like that and then we will receive count
as a perimeter and we will see how we
are going to control the count of our
adults in this method so down below i'm
going to say selection
element something like that and i'm
going to use self dot find element
by id and i will paste the value that i
have copied previously so you can see
that it is xp
double underscore guests double
underscore toggle and i'm going to just
selection element dot click like the
following and now let me pass in some
default value in here like one so we
will not receive arrows when we call
this from run.py and then i will go here
and i will say bot dot select
adults something like that and now let's
see what will happen if we will run our
program
so until now we should expect to see
only this
page being popped up i mean this area
not the page and it looks okay it looks
like it works so we can continue on to
see how we are going to control the
adults for our vacation all right so now
we have to somehow control how we are
going to select the adults count now
this might be a tricky action to take
because say that you want to go with
three adults then it means that in that
case you only need to automate clicking
on the plus sign once because the
default value is two but what if one day
the default value is not going to be two
adults in booking.com say that the
default value is going to be changed to
something like 4 5 3 or any other count
so we can actually be more smarter
rather than trying to automate clicking
on the plus sign depending on whatever
adults count we are going to pass in in
our method so we can first try to
decrease the adult's count to the
minimum value and then we can have more
control how many times we really need to
click on the increasing button so at
first we can write some logic to
decrease the count of adults until the
value reaches one adult because this is
the lowest value of adults that we can
have and then we can try to click on the
plus sign depending on the adult's count
that is passed in so this is a more
generic way to complete this kind of
task and it is going to be very
interesting to implement that so i'm
going to go to our pycharm and you know
what before that we need to understand
how we're going to click on decrease
button so let's do inspect and see how
we are going to identify the element of
decreasing so let's expand this
and
see what is going on here so you can see
that when i hover my mouse in here then
this button of decreasing is being
colored with the green background so
this is the button that we look to
automate clicking on and you can see
that it has a unique value of area label
with the value of decreased number of
adults and i believe that we are going
to see the same thing for increased
number of adults with area label as its
key so i think it should be this one so
if we open this element and see its
attributes so i'm just going to
move here
and all right there it is so you can see
that it has area labeled increased
number of adults so this is the approach
that we're going to identify those
buttons and let me basically
copy this statement and try to find this
element by css selector okay so right
under the select adults method we are
going to use something like decrease
adults
element is equal to self dot find
element by css selector and we are going
to pass in button
and open up and close square brackets
and basically paste the key value
statement that we have copied previously
and you can see that it is area label is
equal to decreased number of adults now
we need to somehow simulate clicking on
that button until the adults count
reaches one because as we said it will
allow us to have more control to
basically decide the adults count so for
that i'm going to use while true and
then inside this while rule we will
write an if statement that will look up
for the value of adults count and once
it reaches the value of 1 then we will
go outside of our while loop so i'm
going to say here while true
and i'm going to go here and basically
fix the indentations and then i'm going
to go down and i'm going to say decrease
adult element dot click now if i leave
the code as it is then it is always
going to try to click on decrease button
which is obviously not what we want but
we want some logic to basically identify
if the value reached the number of one
and if so we'd like to get out of the
while true so it is going to be
something like if the value of
adults
reaches one then we should get out
of
the while loop so let's see how we're
going to identify this so i'm going to
go back to our browser and i'm going to
search for the element that displays the
value so it should be this one in here
where my mouse is pointing let me zoom
in a bit so you can see more clean and
you can see that i'm pointing exactly to
here so let's do inspect and you can see
that it actually depends on this spin
element and you can see that it has the
text of one so what that means it means
that we can try to basically find this
element and see what its value now if i
add here plus then you can see that it
got updated so it means that this is the
exact element that we need now i can
actually see in this inspect page that
we have more elements that are being
updated with the adults count and you
can see up top in input in here
that we let me zoom in
so you can see that this element is
actually getting updated continuously as
well and the reason i want to select
this element is actually because it has
id and if you remember i said that the
id is the strongest attribute that the
html element could have to identify its
uniqueness so if i click on plus here
again then you can see that it gets
updated so i'm going to just find this
element by the id of group adults and
i'm going to go back to pycharm and see
what we can do with this element so i'm
going to go here and say adults value
element is equal to self.find element
by id and it should be the value of
group adults all right so now that we
have control in the element that
displays the value of adults count then
we should somehow receive the count of
the adults now this is something that we
did not learn how we can do because we
only learned about actions like clicking
or sending keys but we did not learn how
we can receive a value of some key in
html elements so it is going to be by
using the adult's value element which we
have identified in here and then it is
going to be basically by launching a
method that is called get attribute now
get attribute is basically a method that
receives a key name and then it tries to
give you back the value of whatever
attribute it is so if we go back to our
browser you can see that we need to work
with this key that is called value
because this is what displays the adults
count right so we need this key so i'm
going to go here and go back to pycharm
and basically pass in here value and
this entire statement should give back
the adults count
should
give back the adults
count
so i'm just commenting this up because
the code is starting to be more complex
so we can remember what each line is
responsible for so
down below i'm going to type in a
conditional and it is going to be much
better if we will assign this entire
statement to a separated variable so you
can say something like adults value is
equal to that entire statement and let
me just write here some split lines
because we want to have more organized
code okay so down below i can say
something like if adults
value is equal to 1 like that now i
already know that this statement is
going to give us back an error because
by default the get attribute returns the
value as strings and we cannot write if
conditionals with comparing string to
integers so we are going to convert this
adult's value to integer exactly in here
and then we are going to check if it is
equal to one now once it equals to one
then we can break the while through so
let's see if this logic works so we
should go ahead and test the run.py file
by executing it and we should see the
adults count being set up to one adult
so now i'm going to test this up
and all right so you can see that it
works perfect the adults has been
changed to
one and the only thing that we have to
do now is identifying this plus button
and basically say that we'd like to go
with 10 adults then we'd like to launch
a for loop that is going to click on
that button nine times so let's go back
to pycharm and implement that now to
really test if it works properly then
really we are going to assume that we
are having 10 adults in our vacation so
i'm just going to pass this argument
when we call this method so
now let's go to our method and minimize
this while rule because we have finished
working with it and we can say increase
button element is going to be equal to
self dot find element by css selector
one more time and if you remember it was
a button
with the key value pair of area
label is equal to and i'm going to open
those double quotes and say increase
with capital i number
of adults with capital a and then i'm
going to go down and i'm going to launch
a for loop applying the range built-in
function so we can really have control
in amount of times that this for loop is
going to execute so i'm going to say for
i in range and we are going to use range
of count minus one because if you
remember i said that we should decrease
this by one to really achieve the exact
count that is passed in in here so we
are going to say increase button element
dot click and that's it now i'm not sure
if you know or not but basically if you
are not going to refer to the variable
that is used in here then by convention
you don't really need to pass in a
variable name like i or a or something
like that you can just use underscore
like that and leave it as it is and this
is just a convention in python that says
that we are not going to make use of the
terrible value so
now we are ready to test the entire
program so i'm going to launch our
run.py file and we should see the adults
count being set to 10. so if we run our
bot
and wait a minute
all right so you can see that it really
works perfect at first we use this
safety logic to basically
set the adults to one and then we have
full control of the adults count that
we'd like to say it now this is really
generic and working perfect because even
if we are going to pass in count equals
to 1 from our method then what is going
to end up happening it is going to go to
here and it is going to try to apply a
for loop in range of zero and it is
never going to run because if you are
having a for loop with range of zero
then you are basically not iterating
over anything so the
adult's count is going to remain one and
that is perfect so this logic really
works and we are basically ready to go
ahead and click on the search button to
really test if we are going to receive
any results so it is going to be very
easy because by convention each search
button in whatever site it is is mostly
having a key value pair that says type
equals to submit something in that kind
so we are going to click on inspect and
see if this is the same for this website
so if we
expand this and go here and look up for
this button and you can see that it has
type equals to submit so again we can
automatically try to basically identify
an element with css selector with html
type of button that has this key value
pair so if we go back to pycharm we can
easily just create one more method that
we can call it click search and we can
basically receive nothing in this method
because there's not going to be any
argument we'd like to pass in
and we are going to say straightforward
self dot find element by css selector
and we should find a button with this
key value pair and basically assign this
to a variable like search
button
and then later on we'd like to click on
that all right so
here i'm just going to call this
bot dot click search
and see if everything works properly now
to really test the entire logic let me
uncomment the change currency and change
this to usd to really see if everything
works and let me challenge this program
a bit and pass in another date so we can
maybe
say here 19 and pass in here 25 and
really test if everything just works and
functions properly even though i have
customized the values a little bit so if
we run our program and basically do
nothing so i'm not going to touch my
mouse at all and see if everything works
okay so currency date adults search
perfect just perfect everything really
works well and we see some results about
different hotels from this booking.com
website and this is just exciting
because we really have some results
going in here and in the next episodes
we are going to dive into more complex
stuff because we need to only identify
the best deals and by saying best deals
we need to somehow automate applying
filtration to that result all right so
here you can see that we have some
results about what we can really book
but as we can understand from this page
we really have multiple options for what
we can filter to basically improve the
results that we receive so for the
purposes of applying some filtrations
then we're gonna need to write some
methods that will be responsible to
apply those filtrations but to do this
in that booking class might lead us to a
situation where we are going to have too
much methods in one class so that's why
we could basically come up with a new
python file that will include some
methods about filtrations once our bot
has reached the page of the results so
if we go back to our python now then we
can actually design our project in the
following way so let me open up
booking.py and we can go down here and
we can say something like
apply filtrations and this filtration is
it should be filtrations and this one
will actually go ahead and instantiate
an instance of another class that could
be named something like booking
filtration something like that and then
in this class we could basically include
some methods that will be responsible to
really go ahead and apply those
filtrations with the selenium driver so
let's go ahead and start working on such
a design so i can go here and i can say
new file and i can name this booking
underscore filtration and then inside
that i can write a comment what is the
purpose of this page so it will be
this
file will
include a class with instance methods
that will be responsible
to interact
with our
website
after
we have some results
to apply filtrations so we could really
understand what this page is about and
right after that we can basically go
down and we can say class booking
filtration
and this class is not going to inherit
from anything so we can go directly
inside
the constructor and actually the
constructor needs to receive one
parameter and this parameter is going to
be actually the driver that we are going
to pass in his argument because we also
need this class to work with the web
driver so if i go to booking.py then we
can actually see that throughout the
process of writing methods we do it on
the self object so we need to somehow
pass the self object to the instantiated
instance of this booking filtration so
this is going to look like something
like driver equals to self in the future
so that's why we should go to our
booking.filtration
and basically receive here driver as a
parameter so before we continue working
on this one let me quickly fix the
arrows in the other file so i will write
here pass to ignore the errors and i
will go to booking.py and i will
basically
go up top of this file and i will say
from booking
dot booking filtration import booking
filtration like that and i will
jump here one more line and i will go
down here and i will say
filtration something like that and i
will basically instantiate the booking
filtration class and i see that i missed
the t here as well so sorry about that
and then later on we can basically
decide what kind of filtrations we want
to apply within this method so that's
actually a good way to design our
program because once we have too much
methods in a class then we might have
tough time to maintain our code in the
long run so that's why designing the
filtrations in the following way could
be a great idea all right so now that we
understood how we could structure the
booking filtrations then let's see some
good candidates for what we can filter
by the results and you can see that we
can basically apply some star rating for
the results so that's going to be the
first method that we're going to write
within the booking filtration file now
you can see that we have this entire box
in here that is responsible to give us
back all those checkboxes so i'd like to
first work with that element because you
can see that we have some more
checkboxes in that page and i don't want
to confuse this five stars for example
with that one because this same checkbox
is appearing also in the popular filters
so that's why it is a better idea to
first take our bot and identify the
element that is responsible to display
this whole area so i'm going to try to
click on inspect in here and i'm going
to do that twice and you can see that we
have this filter category title so the
parent element of this is probably what
is responsible to display all those
check boxes and if we take our mouse to
the parent element in here then you can
see that this is exactly the box because
it also says filter box in its class
name and it also has an id that says
filter underscore class so that is
perfect because we can try to use our
bot to basically select this element
with that id and then we are going to do
something very special that will be
responsible to display all the child
elements of this div element so let's go
ahead and work on that so i'm going to
copy this statement in here and i'm
going to go back to our pycharm and you
can see that i'm inside the booking
filtration file so at first we should
assign the driver to the self object of
this booking filtration class so it is
going to be self.driver is equal to
driver and if you remember this is
always going to receive the original
driver from the booking class itself so
that's why i do this little trick in
here and i can basically launch a method
like apply star rating in
here and this will receive self as a
parameter and now i can use something
like self
dot driver
dot find element by
id
and the id should be filter underscore
class because this is the idea of the
element that we like to filter by now
notice how we did not have auto
completion and this is very annoying
because in libraries that are very large
like selenium we probably always like to
have auto completion for the different
methods to basically make our lives more
easier and the reason that the auto
completion doesn't work it is because
this parameter doesn't have a specific
type now there is actually something in
python that is called typing so we can
really decide the parameters type to
work with auto completions now to show
you an example of how typings are
working then i will use a minute to
explain this with a more familiar type
of variable that we commonly use that is
called a list so say that this class is
actually going to receive one more list
like
my list and we always like to pass in
here list but if we go here and say my
list then we will not have auto
completion for methods like append
remove and stuff that is very related to
lists and again it is because this
parameter doesn't know it's typing so we
could actually do something like from
typing import list and we could go here
and we could say that this one is going
to be
list and now if i was to say dot then
you can see that i have auto completion
for the list methods and the same
approach goes for the driver instances
of selenium we could basically import a
library to decide this driver's type and
it is going to be as easy as going here
and saying from selenium
dot webdriver dot remote
that web driver import web driver like
that and let me remove the examples
because we're really not going to
receive list as a parameter this was
just an example and then i'm going to
say here
column
web
driver and once we have set the type of
this driver parameter then we are always
going to have self.driver
dot and you can see that we have those
autocompletions as expected because now
the self.driver
object knows its type so that's why this
is very useful and now we can go ahead
and basically assign this to a variable
so we can name it something like star
filtration box and then
we could use that and now the next step
should be how to identify the child
elements of some element that we have
selected and this is something that we
can achieve by using css selectors so
let me show you how this could be done
so star child elements this is how i'm
going to name my variable and i'm going
to now use
self.driver and i'm going to use find
elements and not elements so i know that
this is the first time that we use
more than one element as a method but
actually there's also the option to
finding more than one elements in a
website so i'm going to use find
elements by css selector and actually
there's a convention to find all the
child elements of a given element and
that will be by basically using the
asterisk sign inside a string now i want
you to take a look and think about what
is wrong with this statement so we go
ahead and say
self.driver and we launch
on top of that these find elements by
system method so
this will end up giving us
all the elements of this entire webpage
and this is wrong because we only want
the elements of star filtration box
element i mean all the child elements of
it so what we can actually do is we can
remove this self dot driver and we can
replace this with star filtration box
and then this line will be responsible
to give us all the elements that belongs
to that star filtration box element so
now we could go ahead and use something
like print
lan star child elements to really see
that we have some elements stored in
this variable and we can go to
booking.py and we can also use here
something like filtration
dot apply star rating and if you
remember we did not use this method in
our main file which was run dot py so
i'm going to
go here and i'm going to always execute
bot dot apply filtrations and we want to
leave here this method always being
executed and then we will customize what
methods we want to execute in this apply
filtrations method inside the booking.py
file so now let's execute our entire
project so i will run run.py and see
what happens and
in a minute i will also show you the
results in our console because we are
printing something so let's wait for
that all right so if we go back to here
then you can see that we receive as a
result 40. and now inside those 4d
elements we look for the five checkboxes
that we need now if we go back to the
chrome browser again i actually have set
up what are the exact elements that we
need so you can see that i have expanded
here this filter class element and if we
take a look a little bit more down so if
we go to like this area then in here you
can see that it is more focused on the
check boxes and inside of that we have
all those a tags and those a tags are
what really we should click on them and
you can see that each of those a tags
are having some more child classes i
know that it has a very long structure
and you can see that at the end the
inner html of one of the child elements
is one star so what we can actually do
we can try to iterate over those 4d
elements and we can look up for those
that are having the substring of one two
or three or four or five and this is the
same structure for all other stars so if
we go and expand the two stars element
we can actually see that it has at the
end in html with the value of two stars
so those are the elements that we look
to click on them so that's why we can go
to here
and we can basically open up the booking
filtration and we can work on those star
child elements by iterating over each
one of them so we can say for star
element in star child elements and we
could use something that will look like
if
star
underscore element
dot get underscore attribute and we
should receive the attribute
that is really responsible to display
the inner text so it should be inner
html like that so this is a convention
to find the values of what is inside
those html tags so for example if we
were to have a tag that is looking like
that and we have some value like gym
then if we want to receive the gym value
only then you should launch up the get
attribute method so that's why we use
this expression in here and we want to
look if this entire expression here is
equal to something like 1 stars right so
this is what we look up for and of
course i'm not going to hardcode this in
and besides we are going to receive here
something like star
value and we want to turn this to a
formatted string and we want to change
this to star value like that and if this
entire expression is true then we want
to do something now before i go ahead
inside of this if statement let me write
in here pass
at first we want to convert this entire
expression to a string just to be more
safe so i'm going to just do that and
wrap all this expression with the str
method and i'm also going to launch a
method that you maybe seen before that
is called strip now the strip is a
method that will be responsible to clean
all the y spaces because we might have
some white spaces when we want to see
the values of the inner htmls and this
is basically going to be responsible to
clean all of those all right so now i
can go inside of our if conditional and
i can basically say star
element
dot click and the reason i can do this
right now it is because we are going to
iterate over 40 elements and if we have
one element that its inner html is
actually star value stars then we
probably want to click on that so let's
test this in action so i'm going to
basically now run our run dot py but
before we do that we should go to
booking.py because this is where we use
the apply star writing and we should
pass in some star value so let's go
ahead and try to click on five stars so
i'm going to pass in here and let's do
this keyword so we can really understand
what this is about and now we can launch
our bot again so
let's go ahead and do that and let's see
what will happen so we search for some
results as usual
and then
it should go ahead and try to click on
five stars and if we actually
go down then you can see that it clicked
on here so that is perfect and you can
see that this one got also activated and
this is great because we were able to
really achieve our goal all right so now
that we understood this then there is
going to be one more feature that we'd
like to add to this method because this
is just realistic sometimes to search
for results that are kind of like four
stars or above or three stars or above
something in that kind so that's why we
should somehow receive as a perimeter
not just one star value but maybe
receive more than one star value and the
way that we can achieve this is by
turning the star value being arbitrary
argument and that is a way that we can
pass in many arguments to one argument
basically by doing it with adding an
asterisk sign before the parameter name
now if you don't know what this does in
here deeply then i have a video that
explains what is the difference adding
one asterisk sign near a perimeter to
adding double asterisk sign and this is
commonly seen with args or maybe you
have seen previously double asterisk key
w args and if you don't know what are
those then i have a video that explains
the differences between those in the
suggested video so definitely consider
taking a look on that one all right so
now that i have changed this to being an
arbitrary argument then let me change
this to star values because it will be
just more friendly name for that kind of
variable and i can go down and basically
use a statement like for star value
in star values and i can take my entire
code in this area and basically insert
this into a new for loop so it will be
something like that and now that we have
done this then let's test this out with
passing in multiple star values and the
way that we are going to do that is as
easy as going to booking.py and besides
passing in one single value let's try to
pass in three
four and also five so we should see the
results that their star rating is 3
stars or above so if we run our program
now and wait a few seconds then let's
see what will happen
so as usual we see the regular behaviors
in the searching results
all right so if we take a look in here
then you can see that we have activated
those star ratings and if we actually
take a look in your filters box then you
can also see that it has been activated
successfully so we have done a really
great job implementing the star rating
to this booking.com website and we can
continue from here all right so you can
definitely understand that there is no
limit for the filtrations that you can
apply right after you are inside the
results page so i'm going to add one
more method for the purposes of this
tutorial that i personally think that is
very useful and i think if we could have
the option to take our bot to click on
the sorting option from lowest price to
higher then it is going to be very very
useful so if we take a look in the
results page then you can actually see
that up top we have some more
filtrations or basically just some more
utilities that can help us to customize
our results better you can see that we
have the option of clicking price lowest
first so we would like to automate
clicking on that and i'm going to click
on inspect and you can see that this is
just a button
with only this attribute in here which
we have to find to probably click on
that and that is going to be this data
id is equal to price so we can grab this
key value attribute and find this with
css selector and basically try to click
on that one so we can go back to our
pycharm and basically to our booking
filtration file and we can design here
one more method and we could name this
sort price lowest
first and this is just going to try to
find an element so we can name it just
element and that will be equal to self
dot driver
dot find
element
by css selector and this will be that
one and this will just receive li
because this was the element type and we
will open up our square brackets and we
will say data id
is equal to actually i copied this
statement so excuse me about that and i
can just paste in
data id is equal to price make sure to
use double quotes in price and then down
below i can say element.click and that
will be it now if you remember this is
only the page that we write our methods
but we don't actually call them and the
place that we call them is inside this
booking.py file inside apply filtrations
so right after we apply some star
writing we could also sort our results
so we could say filtration
but sort price lowest first and this is
not going to receive anything as
perimeter so we are not going to pass
any arguments and now let's test this
entire program now in action and let me
actually test our program a bit and
only use four to five stars all right so
if we run this then
and wait a bit let's see what will
happen
all right so you can see that we have
also activated the price lowest first
button as you can really see that we
have some more cheaper results now in
the first page and if we take a look in
our filtrations then you can see that we
got four stars and five stars so i think
this will be pretty much enough about
the filtrations that you can apply if
you want to basically see useful results
of course there are more things that you
can apply to receive better results and
as you can see the technique of that it
is pretty much going to be similar to
finding the elements with the different
methods that you can use within the
selenium library alright so one of the
first things that we are going to do in
this episode is to support running this
project not always from an id because in
some cases you only want to execute dbot
to do its actions and to receive some
results and for doing such action you
maybe not always want to open it in a
specific ide
further than that sometimes executing
bots from the command line is just more
comfortable rather than going to pycharm
and basically pointing to your project
and then using the shortcut of shift f10
to execute your project sometimes you
only want to do it from a terminal
executing python and then referring to
the file in our case it is run.py now
i'm not gonna lie to you but our project
currently does not support such a
behavior because we have this tricky
line inside the booking.py file that is
going to add the location of our driver
pad to the
path environment variable now executing
such a line from pycharm will work
because pycharm knows how to take this
line and attach it to a python process
and really add this location to the path
system variable but when it comes to
other processes that we want to execute
the project from them for example a
command line interface in windows then
we are going to have some troubles
because we need to add the location of
our selenium drivers before we execute
the project so it is going to be tricky
to handle that from the terminal level
and i'm actually going to prove you that
our project won't execute successfully
if we will try to run the run.py file
from a terminal so if you remember in
this directory we have this file which
we look to execute and if i was to say
python run dot py then you can see that
it complains about how the chrome driver
executable needs to be in pat so i'm
going to fix that so you will have the
ability to execute this project from
your terminal it doesn't matter if you
work within linux environment or if you
work with a windows environment all
right so the way that we're going to fix
that is by using try and accept blocks
and we can actually try to execute those
lines of code and if we will have some
errors then we could always print to our
users that the user needs to basically
execute some line from a command line
that will add the c selenium drivers
folder to the path system variable so
let's go ahead and try to design that so
i'm going to grab all those lines of
code in here and i'm going to indent all
of those once and i'm going to wrap it
up with the try block now
right after this we can go down here and
we could say accept any exception and we
could grab the exception inside the
variable something like e maybe and as a
starter we could say something like
print
there is a problem running this
program from command line interface so
that is just a great start handling
things inside the accept block of course
there is going to be some more additions
in the future so i'm going to go back to
our terminal and i'm just going to run
the same command so it is going to be
python
run dot py and you can see that now we
automatically see this there is a
problem running this program from
command line interface because we were
able to hit the accept log because we
really have some exception but in some
other cases we might also have some
problems directly in our bot now not all
the exceptions in the world are about
how the chrome driver is not inside the
pad so that's why it is quite dangerous
to output something like that for all
the exceptions that are going to occur
in our program so that is why we need to
verify that we really hit this message
that says chrome driver executable needs
to be in pat so
that's why we could go back to pycharm
and we could verify that the message is
really about how there is not a folder
inside the system path so we could say
if str
e so that is a way to cache the
exception message and we could go back
to terminal and check the substrings of
this specific exception so if we were to
check if this in path is a substring in
the exception message then it really
means that the problem is about how the
chrome driver executable needs to be in
pack so i'm going to go back to pycharm
and i'm going to say if
in pat inside a string like that
in
the exception message then we could go
down and we could print this message but
if we have some other problem say that
we have a problem with selenium say that
we have a syntax problem then we would
like to raise the original problem and
that is achievable by easily saying else
and basically using the keyword or
phrase like that now the minute that you
are doing something like this then once
we don't hit that specific problem then
we really raise the original exceptions
so that is a great way to handle the
exceptions so now we could verify that
this works so we could go back to our
terminal and we could clean the screen
for a minute and we could say again
python
run dot py and you can see that we again
receive this message so that means that
our if conditional works great now to be
honest i am going to change this message
to be more friendly so the user could
understand what command needs to be
executed to add the location of our
chrome drivers to the path system
environment variable so i'm going to
grab a code snippet that i prepared as a
print message and i'm just going to
paste this in in here and obviously you
can grab this from my website in the
eighth episode of our entire series so
you can see that here i have a nicer
message that says you are trying to run
the bot from command line and backslash
n is just an escaping characters to just
jump to the next line so in the next
line we say please add to pat your
selenium drivers and for windows use
this command now i know that this looks
a little bit complex but that is
actually a built-in windows command that
we can execute to add some more
locations to our already existing path
system environment variable now as i
said in the first episodes our path
environment variable has already around
50 or even 100 locations that we have as
a value so that's why we
use set path and we add the original
paths and in addition that's why we have
semicolon we add our path which is going
to be c selenium drivers or whatever
folder you have set up the chrome driver
into it and if you use linux then you
should execute this line which is
looking pretty much similar only the
windows includes the set command all
right so now we could basically go to
our terminal and again run this command
and now you can see that we have a very
friendly message so the only thing that
i have to do now is grab this and paste
this in and now really customize the pad
that we should add here so it will be
selenium drivers once again and i'm not
always sure if it needs to be added with
a backslash at the end or not so i'm
going to try both and i recommend for
you to try both as well so let's try
that and then try to run pythonrun.py
and you can see that i again receive
this message so let me clean the screen
and run the same command with a
backslash at the end and again executing
python run.py and now you can see that
our bot works and you can see that
everything is pretty much functioning as
expected you'll see that we were able to
search the results you can see that we
were able to filter out and also
applying the sorting so this means that
it works perfect and if we take a look
to our terminal then you can see that we
actually receive some warnings that we
are really going to fix soon but at all
in the big picture our bot functions
perfect if we even execute it from a
terminal all right so now you might
notice some weird warnings about david
tools listening to our local host with
some port etc so that is actually
something that we did not see before but
actually when we work with browsers like
chrome which is in our case chrome
driver then chrome now comes built in
with some dev tools that is a set of web
developer tools built in directly into
google chrome browser and i think when
it recognizes that we execute some
automated chrome browser to run some
test cases or basically automating
websites then it already executes that
utility now in this tutorial i'm not
going to cover too much about dev tools
so that is why we can allow ourselves to
ignore those kind of errors and to
ignore those kind of arrows in that
stage we need to go back to our
booking.py file and basically add some
additional configurations to our web
driver instance so it is going to be as
easy as going back to pycharm and add
some lines in this file in here and if
you remember we have some line that says
super that is really responsible to
instantiate an instance of the inherited
class and as well as the class that we
are writing just in that moment so
that is why we need to customize this
line because we need to pass in some
additional options to this class that we
inherit so it is going to be
something like that so we are going to
say options
is equal to
web driver dot chrome options and you
can see that it is just a built-in class
that i instantiate and then i can say
something like options
dot add
experimental option and i'm just going
to write in here some strings that will
be responsible to ignore those kind of
errors and i'm not going to lie i search
a lot about this dev tools and why do we
see those warnings so i ended up by
grabbing this code from a stack overflow
poll which i will add in the description
so you can take a deeper look in the
discussion that is going on there all
right so it will be exclude
switches
like that pay attention that these
switches is with a capital s and then
there is going to be one additional
value that i will pass in here which is
going to be accepted inside a list with
one element and it is going to be enable
dash logging
like that and once i have done this then
we need to grab the options which is
equal to an instance of chrome options
and we need to pass this in in the
initialization line so it is going to be
options is equal to options like that
and then once i have done this then
let's test out if we still see those
logs so i'm going to open back our
terminal and i'm going to say again
python run dot py
and i'm just going to let our bot
running and in the background let's see
what is going on with the terminal and
you can see that now since we ignore
those kind of logs then we really don't
see anything and you can see that our
bot finished its job and that is perfect
as we can see the results in this chrome
browser page so that is one way that we
can ignore those kind of arrows and we
can continue from here all right so now
that we were able to figure this out
then there's going to be one more thing
that we'd like to test in this stage now
we like to test if we will really see
the original exception even if we are
having an exception that is not about
the chrome driver being in the path so
that's why let's do something wrong in
our project by purpose so i'm going to
go to our python and i'm going to say
here a is equal to two
divided
by zero like that and we should receive
basically a zero division error before
even our bot starts so that is why we
should now go back to our terminal again
and let's clean the screen and try to
execute our bot one more time
and see the results
all right so you can see that we see now
the original exception which says to us
zero division error because we really
try to divide a number by zero so we
will have some errors and you can see
how our bot did not even start executing
the lines of code because we had some
early exception so that is perfect and
this is a great preparation for the
future of this bot project and we can
now continue extend our application as
much as we want and even test this with
a terminal now the main reason that i
really want the ability to execute this
project from a terminal that is because
if you remember from the preview of the
bot then we'd like to visualize the
results of the deals in a nice way so
the user can really have a greater look
on what are the results for the best
deals and we probably want to avoid
doing that with the pycharm and we
probably want to visualize it nice with
terminal so that is why i want the
ability to execute this bot from any
terminal even if it's a windows
environment or even if it is a linux
environment all right so let's look into
the next element that we should identify
in order to start reporting the results
to the user that uses this bot so as
expected i'm going to run this project
now from the terminal and i'm going to
make use of this recommendation that we
have generated in the print line so we
can really have the drivers folder under
the patch system environment variable so
i'm going to execute those lines and as
you can notice i replaced this path with
my original path so i'm going to run
that and right after that i'm going to
say python run.py exactly like the
previous episode now
just a reminder if you remember i showed
some exception by purpose in the end of
the last tutorial and i deleted that and
it was a zero division error so make
sure that you have deleted this and then
i can go back to our browser and you can
see that we have the results as expected
and the filtrations and the sorting are
pretty much fine all right so
now we should look into that large
element that is responsible to display
all the results now i'm going to be
honest with you i'm not going to show
how you can see all the 170 results but
we are going to just stick for the first
page for the purposes of this tutorial
so that means that we should identify an
element that has 25 child elements that
are responsible to display all those
boxes that are displaying the deals
price hotel's name and star rating and
stuff like that all right so let's get
started now again our goal is going to
be first to find that parent element
that is responsible to display all those
25 boxes that each one of the boxes are
responsible as you see to display the
hotel's name and star rating and stuff
like that so at first let me try to find
the element that is pretty much covering
the entire box so i scrolled up to the
first result and let's click here on
inspect and i will do that twice so
excuse me about that and as you can see
this is for example the title of the
first box and if i scroll up a bit and
here for example we only see the part
that is without the image which is again
not what we want we want the entire box
and as you can see this one is
responsible to display the entire box
and if i minimize this element and you
can see that now if i take my mouse to
the second one then you can see that
the second box has been covered with
blue background so this means that those
div tags that are having
maybe the data score or data hotel id
are what responsible to display each one
of the boxes and you can also see that
the parent element of all of those is a
div tag with the id of hotel list inner
now before we go ahead and start writing
this in the python side let me show you
some tricks that you could have done in
the javascript side of the web pages now
don't be afraid of javascript i know
that this is a programming language that
there's a great change that you did not
practice it but i'm just going to make a
short walkthrough how i identified when
i developed this project all of those 25
boxes so let's go to console all right
so console is actually an area that you
can execute pure javascript code that is
going to be responsible to identify each
one of the elements that we look for so
if we go to console and we ignore what
is going on here and let me zoom in a
bit so you can see everything
and i am first going to clean everything
in here so it is going to be clear and
then this is a method that we should
execute so
like that and then you'll have a clean
console now to grab all the elements
that are responsible to display this
page then we can use the built-in
document statement now this is again
from javascript so don't confuse it with
python but i just want to make a short
walkthrough how i identified the
elements that i need so you can execute
a method that is pretty much similar
like in selenium and now it is called
get element by id now pay attention that
e
b and the i are capitalized and then i'm
going to say here hotel list underscore
inner and if you remember this was the
id that is responsible to display all
the results and i'm going to assign this
whole expression to a variable we can
name it like
um
hotel
list and this is going to be equal to
that expression and you can see that
once i click on enter then you can see
that it returns me the element that is
responsible to display all those boxes
now i'm again going to clear the screen
and
work with the hotel list library and i
mean the variable and then on top of
that i'm going to execute get
elements
by class name so e b c and n are
capitalized and i'm going to
find here the class name that is pretty
much unique for each box so i actually
found this sr underscore
property block string as unique per each
box now you can see that even before i
executed this it is going to be
responsible to give me back 25 elements
so what that means
it means that now we have the control of
all those 25 elements that we can work
with so if i press on enter then you can
see that we have a result with 25
elements so again this is what we need
to do on the selenium side we should
first find that parent element with the
hotel list inner id and then on top of
that we should go ahead and execute find
elements by class name and we should
pass in this value so let's translate
what we have done here to python and i
think that the fact that i showed you
this on the javascript side is just one
more utility that could be useful for
you all right so we are inside pycharm
inside the booking.py file and i'm just
going to go down here and type in one
more method that we can call it report
results and then inside this method we
are going to say self dot find element
by id
and it is going to receive hotel list
underscore inner and then on top of that
we are going to execute dot find
elements
by
class
name
and let's actually split the line so we
can have a cleaner look so i'm going to
do that in here
and
this by class name is going to receive
as argument sr underscore property
underscore block and i need to assign
this entire expression to some variables
so we can name it hotel underscore
boxes this is going to be equal to that
one and actually let's test first that
this works so i'm just going to say
return hotel boxes and i'm going to go
to our run.py and i'm going to say print
the length of bot dot report results
because if you remember this is
returning a list and we only like to see
the length of this list and of course
this should return us 25 and if it is
then it means that we are ready to
continue on the further actions so i'm
just going to go to our terminal and i
am again going to execute python run dot
p y and let's wait for the results of
that all right so the filtrations have
been applied now if i go to terminal
then you can see that we receive 25 back
so this means that we have done a great
job receiving all those boxes that are
responsible to display data about the
deals all right so now that we have the
control on each of the boxes then we
should somehow try to pull the specific
data that we need and obviously we'd
like to start with the hotel's name so
we should find a pattern to get the
title of all the 25 deals so let's try
to find this up so i'm going to open our
latest browser and see what is going on
here so let's go to our first box and
try to click on inspect and if you
remember this is under the elements that
we have found so this means that we can
iterate over each one of the 25 boxes
and we can try to find an element by a
class name that is equal to sr dash
hotel underscore underscore name so i'm
going to remember that and start working
on that one now i want to start working
on a new file now because we want to
have the reporting in a separate python
file to basically have more organized
project so i'm going to go to the
booking directory and i'm going to
create a file that we can name this
booking underscore
report and let's document first what
this file is about so
this
file is going to include
methods that will parse
the specific data that we need from each
one of the
deal boxes so this explanation is pretty
much making sense all right so down here
we are going to have a class that is
going to be responsible to have some
methods that will start to display the
data that we need in a nice table so i'm
going to start by saying
class
booking
report and then this will not inherit
from anything so
we are ready to straightforward to
receive something inside our constructor
now what is making sense the most is
probably to receive as a parameter the
parent element that is responsible to
display all those deal boxes so i'm
going to receive as a parameter
something like boxes section
element and then i'm going to say here
self dot
boxes section
element is equal to that one and then we
are going to instantiate an instance of
this one and we are going to pass in the
element with the id of hotel list inner
so let's work on that so i'm going to go
here and i'm going to basically go up
top and i'm going to use from
booking dot booking report import
booking report and i'm going to go down
and i'm going to say
report is equal to
booking
report and i'm going to pass in the
hotel boxes so excuse me for
instantiating this before that one it is
wrong so i'm going to just fix that and
i'm going to just move it
and actually replace this with the
return because we really don't want this
to return anything for now so i'm just
going to instantiate it in here and then
i'm going to pass in
hotel boxes like that now i'd actually
like to
execute these find elements by class
name on the booking report side so i'm
just going to cut this from here and
only pass in the element with that
specific id and now let me basically
remove this empty line from here and i
think that will be it so later on we can
basically execute some methods from the
booking report class like i don't know
um display
table stuff like that i know that this
method doesn't exist but i'm just
assuming the future of our project so
let me delete that and actually there
should be one more area that we should
remove everything and this should be
this one so
let's also remove the execution from
here and continue designing this all
right so now i'm inside booking.py file
and i'm going to just leave everything
here as it is and i'm just going to
continue working on booking report okay
so now that we have an html element
inside this box section element then we
should go and execute find elements by
class name on top of it so we will have
all those 25 elements back so i'm going
to just type in a method that will say
pull
deal boxes and this will receive self as
a perimeter and i'm going to say self
excuse me this should be self dot boxes
section element dot find
element by class
name and this will have the argument as
sr property
block
and again this is just going to pull all
those 25 elements and what i want to do
now is actually instantiate one more
list inside our init method and i'm just
going to say here return to
all the expression in here and i'm going
to say in the init method self.deal
boxes is equal to pull
self.pull deal boxes and then we will
have control for all the elements
under this name which is making much
more sense and i'm sorry that i missed
the s right after find element so
obviously this should be find elements
by class name because we would like to
pull all the elements that are matching
this class
name all right so now that we have done
this then again you might have noticed
that we did not have any auto completion
about defined elements by class name and
that is because we did not have typing
for the box section element and we are
already familiar with this from the
seventh episode so now that is going to
be a very similar action to what we have
seen previously throughout this series
and it is just going to be importing the
typing for the web element class and
then basically use this specific typing
so i'm going to say here from
selenium.webdriver
dot remote
dot web element
import web element like that and then
i'm going to say that this boxes section
element is going to be in kind of
web
element like that and then we will start
having auto completions as expected all
right so now that we have done this then
let's start pulling in the data that we
really need from each one of the boxes
and as a great starter we'd like to
first pull the hotel name for each one
of the boxes and if you remember i said
that we have a specific spin tag with
this unique class name that says sr
hotel underscore underscore name so i'm
going to find all the elements with that
class name so it will be
going back to pycharm and say something
like def
pull titles
so i can
receive self here as a parameter and
then i'm going to basically iterate over
each one of the boxes so it is going to
be 4
deal box in self dot deal boxes
and i will say deal box dot find
element
by class
name and we will paste in the value of
the class that we are looking for which
is sr hotel underscore underscore name
and then what we like to do with this
element is basically pulling its inner
html because if you have noticed in here
this element has the hotel name inside
its inner html which you can really see
from here so it is just going to be as
easy as saying to that expression
something like that so let me first
split this to multiple lines and then i
can say on top of that dot get
attribute and we would like to receive
the inner html of that element and if
you remember when i used the get
attribute in your html i also executed
some method that will be responsible to
delete all the white spaces and if you
remember it was dot strip like that and
that will be it this entire expression
should really display the hotel's names
so let me first assign this entire
expression to a variable like hotel name
or deal name doesn't really matter and
then we can basically try to use here
print
hotel name and see if that works now if
you remember poll titles is not called
anywhere so i'm just going to go to
booking.py and i'm going to launch the
methods that we need to report the
results in this report results method so
it will be report
dot pull
titles and now let's see what is going
on in the run.py file and if you
remember we removed the report result
section so in that case it should be
what dot report results and i'm just
going to leave everything here as it is
and now our bot should be responsible to
display all the hotels
names so if we go to our terminal and
say again python run.py then let's see
the results and as expected we change
the currency we add new york and one
adult and we apply the filtrations
and we sort the prices and now let's see
what we have in the terminal and you can
see that we really have all the hotels
names we really have everything that we
need
so we really have here 25 hotels and
let's actually see if the sorting
matches our convention so the first
hotel should be
he had placed new york city times square
and if we go here you can see that it
doesn't quite match and i know the
reason for that because sometimes you
probably need to refresh after receiving
those kind of results and we probably
don't want to execute pulling each one
of the titles too much fast and i
remember that this was a workaround that
i applied when i developed this project
before i presented to you now so what
i'm going to do before pulling the
results i'm just going to trigger a
refresh to that page so
the bot will have a second or two to
basically grab the data properly so i'm
just going to go to pycharm and i'm
going to say here bot dot refresh and
this workaround should do the trick so
i'm just going to say here
a work around to
let our bot to grab
the data properly now let me try to
execute our bot one more time and see
now if it is going to work as expected
now i think that the reason happens it
is because we try to pull the data and
this sorting didn't finish its job so it
makes sense to refresh everything before
we really try to pull all the titles so
let's just clean the screen and say
python run dot py and wait again a few
seconds
okay so now the first hotel is hotel
edison times square and if we go to our
terminal and then you can see that the
first hotel is hotel edison times square
and the second one should be holiday inn
and the third one should be pot times
square so let's verify that okay so i
think that now the results are displayed
as expected this refresh really gives
our bot a second to breed and to grab
the data in the ordering that we want
now i want to do something important
before i go ahead with this tutorial and
that will be changing the amount of the
check-in date and the check-out date and
this is because it has been a week or
two weeks since i recorded the last
episode in this series so i just want to
make sure that the dates are going to
match the today's date so that's why i'm
just going to jump the dates by one
month only by changing those to zero six
besides zero five all right so now we
are ready to continue to customize the
data that we need now we said that we'd
like to customize the data in a nice
table where we will display the hotel's
name price and also storing the hotel's
score meaning the rating could be a
great idea so if you remember we ended
up by customizing inside the booking
report file this pull titles method and
this one is actually going over each of
the deal boxes and tries to pull some
attribute that is going to be useful for
us so we could take as advantage that we
iterate over each one of the deal boxes
and we could actually try to pull the
price in the score along the way so
that's why i'm going to remove the
printing line from here and i'm just
going to comment out what i'm doing in
each iteration step so i will comment
here
pulling the hotel name and then later on
i'm also going to change the pool titles
to more generic function like pull deal
box
attributes something in that kind and
now i'm going to go over and start
basically pulling the prices now to save
some time then i'm just going to show
here what was the approach of finding
the price on each deal box and as well
as how i found the score of each hotel
so that's why i'm going to
straightforward say here hotel
underscore price and that will be equal
to deal underscore box
dot find element by class name and then
the value here is going to be so let's
open up strings and then i'm going to
say bui
dash price
dash display
underscore underscore value and so if i
have a class with this value then it
means that this is going to give us the
price so that's why i can allow myself
to do that now i'm going to use the same
approach of getting the inner html
attribute and deleting the white spaces
and if you remember we have done this in
the hotel name as well so i'm going to
copy that and paste this in and that
line i mean those three lines will be
responsible to pull the hotel price and
then if we go down below and we also say
here hotel
score and that will be by deal box
dot
get attribute and there's a great reason
why i use here get attribute and not
emitted with find element by something
and that is because this element has
already an html attribute that looks
like data dash score and so what that
means it means that if we were to pull
only the value of this attribute in here
then it means that we are going to
receive back the hotel score in scale of
10 so an hotel score could be 8.5 9.1
9.5 and so on and so now that i have
done this then again i'd like to clean
the white spaces so just for safety i'm
only going to launch here dot strip like
we did previously with price and hotel's
name all right so now that we have a
name price and score for each one of the
deal boxes then let's test first our
program now i'm going to do something
that might look weird to you but i will
explain just in a minute why i'm doing
this so in order to test this out then
i'm going to go up here and i'm going to
use a list that i want to name it
something like collection and that is
going to be equal to an empty list and
then as we keep iterating over name
price and score i'm basically going to
need to add those
attributes to this collection so we
could have an organized and structured
data and i'm going to use nested lists
here where the collection will be the
list that will include multiple lists
and each list that it is going to have
is going to include three elements and
one of them is going to be name the
other one price and the third one is
going to be score so i'm going to use
here something like collection
dot append and then i'm going to add to
that one more list and then i will say
hotel name
hotel
price
and the other one should be hotel score
and now that i have done this then i
really want to test out if i have all
the data that i wanted to pull from the
beginning so i'm going to use here
return collection and i'm going to go
back to our booking.py file and i'm
going to search for the method where we
report the results and i think this
should be here and then i'm going to
launch here the method that we have just
finished to design and that is going to
be poll deal box attributes now if you
remember we used return statements so
when we execute this line straight
forward then we are not going to see
anything so we're going to need to wrap
this up with the print built built-in
statement so that we will be able to see
the data all right so now that we have
done this then let's open our terminal
and test the results so i'm going to
bring our terminal to here and i'm going
to say python
run dot p
y
and let's see if everything is going to
function correctly now let me move the
web browser to the screen and let's see
what will happen all right so the bot is
running and now we should see in the
console of our terminal the result so
i'm going to open that up and let's zoom
out a bit so we can understand what is
going on here all right so you can see
that we are sort of having a weird
output but let me break down what is
going on here so you can see that the
first and the last characters are
actually square brackets because this is
the collection of data that we have now
and you can see that this includes the
list of
first hotel and then
the second hotel and then the third
hotel and so on now i'm not sure why we
see here an empty string and that is
probably because this webster square 30
day rentals does not have a score so
that's why it is an empty list and you
can see that as i keep going we are
having a list inside one bigger list
that each list represents a collection
of data about hotel name hotel price and
also hotel score and that is a great
start to visualize our data with the
pretty table library that i talked about
in the very beginning of this series and
again this library is going to help us
to visualize the data in a nice table
divided into columns and rows and now
let's see what we need to do in order to
be able to visualize our data nicer all
right so let's go ahead and see how to
visualize our data now so i'm going to
clean the screen and i'm going to
install a library that is called pretty
table so it is going to be pip install
pretty
table like that now for those that are
asking why i'm not using virtual
environment here right now because i'm
installing a library on the system
interpreter you can go ahead and do that
because it will help you to basically
have organized environment for this
specific project i just don't feel like
going through something in few seconds
at least if i don't have a full tutorial
on that on my channel so that's why i'm
going to straightforward install those
packages in the system interpreter and
i'm going to rely on that on this
project but if you feel comfortable
using virtual environments then i really
welcome you to do so because this is a
nicer way to organize your projects in
your machine all right so now i will use
this line and you can see that i have
this installed so it means that we can
work with this library so now i'm going
to go back to our pycharm and see how we
could work with that all right so now
that we have the collection of data in
here then we are going to write here few
more lines to basically display this in
a table so i'm going to scroll up and
i'm going to import the pretty table
library but i'm going to import only one
class from this library so it is going
to be from pretty
pretty table
import pretty table like the following
and then we need to instantiate this
class and so it is going to be here so
i'm going to say
right here something like that so i will
use here table
is equal to pretty table and this one is
going to receive few arguments and the
first one is very important which is the
field names now i said that in the table
we are going to have columns so in our
case we probably want to declare here
three columns and the first one will be
the name and then the price and then the
score so i'm going to pass here straight
forward a list that is going to look
like the following so i'm going to use
here hotel
name
and then i'm going to use hotel
price and then i'm going to use hotel
score like that and again those are
going to be used as the columns so let
me use actually
a keyword parameter in here so we can
understand all right so now that i
passed this argument then we need to go
ahead and create some rows in our table
so it is going to be as easy as using
the add rows method and then we are
allowed to pass a collection of data and
guess what we are going to pass in the
nested list that i created a few minutes
ago so that's why in
here i used a nested list so it will be
easier for us to basically pass in
directly this collection list object so
it is going to make our lives very easy
so now the only thing that we need to do
in this booking.py file is going to be
table
dot add underscore rows and then we can
basically pass in whatever this returns
in here so it is going to be just
copying and pasting this right there and
then i'm going to basically
leave it as it is and actually we need
to print the table itself so excuse me
for deleting the print line before now
we need to print the table itself to
really see the real table with columns
and rows all right so now that we are
ready now let's go back to our terminal
and actually clean the screen and run
our bot so it is going to be python run
dot py again
and let's see what will be the results
so i'm going to display the results in
here and we will see in the background
just in a few seconds the table that we
expect to see so
now
you can see that we have this nice
organized table that is really
responsible to display everything that
you need about the deals that you read
from the booking website and you can see
that it is very very organized and you
can see that it is with the sorting of
lower to higher because we have applied
this filtration throughout this series
and you can see that it is just more
easier to read the data in that way and
you can also use this pretty table
library for different projects as well i
really like this library to visualize
data when i need to do some tasks and i
want to display the data that i receive
back usually i work with this library
because it really displays the data
nicer and it is just more comfortable to
look at all right so now that we have
completed this then it could have been
nicer to control each time how we want
to execute our bot so we might want to
see results for different locations in
the future and for sure we also like to
change our check-in date and check out
date depending on what is the exact time
that we want to prepare for a location
so that's why maintaining those kind of
information in the code itself might not
be a great idea so that's why what we
can do exactly like i showed in the very
beginning of this series how the project
is developed from the beginning is to
turn those hard-coded strings into being
inputs and then we will have the ability
to ask the user about those kind of
pieces of information so we could have
here something like input and then we
could ask here where you want to go and
then what will end up happening is that
the string that i'm going to pass in
here as the input is automatically going
to be passed in inside this bot dot
select place to go method and so it will
be useful because now we will not have
to change the code every time that we
want to look up for a different location
to prepare our vacation so that's why
i'm going to do this approach for
check-in date and check-out date and as
well as adults count and i'm going to
leave the currency as it is because it
will probably be nicer to see the prices
in united states dollars you can change
it to whatever currency you want but
let's leave it just hard coded in here
and only change those all right so i'm
going to ask here besides hard coding in
the check-in date something like
this so i'm going to ask what is the
check in date and now i will also copy
this statement and
paste this in
here and then i will ask what is the
check out date and
i will also ask here
something like
how many people
something like that and then we are
ready to go okay so now i will allow
myself to run again python
run dot p y and let's see what will
happen so at first we see our program
and you can see that nothing will happen
only after we select our currency
because our program expects for an input
from us so it is going to be now
answering each step at a time so it is
going to be something like so let's say
that we want to go to
los angeles now so i'm going to
put that and you can see that now it
asks for me what is the check index so
now if i open the browser then we can
see that it has already selected the los
angeles so that is perfect it means that
it really works and we should see the
exact same result when we provide in
check-in and check-out date now we
should be careful in here because we
want to give the correct format so it
will be year
dash month and only the day of the month
right after that so i'm going to use
that and then i will say check out date
something like the following so let's
say we want to go for five days and then
you'll see that it asks for how many
people and meanwhile i can check if this
worked and you can see that it filled in
the correct information and now i will
provide in four people for example
and you can see that we receive an error
and i believe that is because we did not
convert
the
count of adults to an integer now by
default so this is a great mistake that
we had in here and let's fix this
quickly so let's bring our program and
explain what is going on here so you can
see that in select adults if we use here
control b
you can see that here we are operating
some actions that are requiring from
this count to being an integer and you
can see that exactly from this line
where we use -1 so it complains about
how a string could not use subtracting
in here so that's why we should go ahead
and automatically convert this to an
integer so i'm going to use an int
built-in function here and allow myself
to execute this program one more time so
let's clean the screen and again use
python
run dot py
and let's minimize this up and then
provide in the information
so it's going to be los angeles
and then it is going to be again
this date and then
that checkout date and then we can say
four and you can see that now we don't
receive any errors so i believe in few
seconds we should see the results in a
nice table and you can see that exactly
this is what is going on here and we
actually have a hotel with 10 scores so
that is great news about this grand park
la 30 day stage
and okay so you can really see that the
results are perfect and everything
functions well and the fact that we use
input could really help us to execute
this program every time that we want to
test out the results for different
locations and as well as for different
dates so we could select the next month
or the next three weeks or even tomorrow
so we will have this dynamic option to
just providing the information once we
run the program and we don't really need
to change the code every time all right
so i think this will be it about
designing this selenium project now of
course there is always room for
improvement and also adding some
features here and there but i think that
i have covered everything that i wanted
to accomplish from the very beginning
and that is the fact that we display the
results in a console in a nice way
depending on the information that has
been provided in where we want to go and
the check-in check-out date and how many
people so if you enjoyed this series
then be sure to hit the like button and
drop a comment so we can really spread
this video to more people on youtube and
i will see you in my future videos so
again hit the thumbs up button and as
well as subscribe to my channel and see
you around